car paula c'est comme dans les chalets
guerre pause qui est devant nous et ce
qu'on ne voit pas bien je crois que on
peut on peut ouvrir notre on peut ouvrir
notre séance je suis très heureux je
suis très heureux mes chers collègues
d'accueillir au nom de la commission
le ministre jean yves le drian pour deux
raisons prend fin d'abord parce qu on
est toujours heureux
et puis ensuite pour deux raisons pour
deux raisons principales c'est que ça
fait très longtemps que jean yves le
drian n'a pas pu venir sauf et c'était
au combien important pour présenter et
insister participer à au débat sur le
vote de la loi
mais pour le tour d'horizon général de
la situation diplomatique
on a à regarder et vous n'êtes pas venu
parmi nous depuis le 25 novembre c'est à
dire pile à sainte catherine
ce qui est quand même assez ancien
depuis lors vous êtes marié à cette
commission n'est ce pas oui oui oui j'ai
rarement vous venez chez moi
absolument c'est absolument pas c'est
absolument pas la moindre
le moindre reproche que nous avons dans
les dernières semaines nous avons eu
l'adoption du rapport sur la pandémie
c'était les dernières semaines d'action
fut-elle lointaine de marielle de sarnez
puis après le vote de la loi et la
seconde raison de ma grande satisfaction
c'est l'événement qui vient de se
produire tout à l'heure je pense que
cette commission et le gouvernement et
cette commission peut être légitimement
fiers de la façon dont le vote a été
vraiment très très très unanime emporté
par par l'assemblée je crois que c'est
quelque chose de très précieux nous
avons donné globalement avec nos nos
différences de sensibilité nos positions
nos critiques donc nos approbation nous
avons donné je crois de façon globale
une image très satisfaisante de la
représentation nationale à travers le
débat en commission en plénière et à
travers ce le vote de cette loi
donc je pense que c'est un très très
gros effort qui a été portée
principalement mais pas exclusivement
par hervé berville que notre rapporteur
et qui s'est conclue d'une façon est
extrêmement satisfaisant
donc voilà les raisons pour lesquelles
je suis très heureux alors évidemment il
s'est passé on peut pas dire que l'on
n'a pas coulé sous les ponts depuis que
nous avons fait ce tour de ce dernier
tour d'horizon je crois que le fait
majeur de l'actualité internationale
ça a été l'installation de
l'administration by donne alors c'est
évidemment un peu prématuré pour en
saisir toutes les implications mais déjà
beaucoup de signes ont été envoyées par
cette nouvelle administration qui mérite
qu'on s'y arrête pour pour les analyser
et pour commencer même 2d de voir
comment un pays comme la france et des
pays comme les pays européens
ils réagissent on n'abordera pas je
crois qu'on est toujours n'est d'accord
avec le ministre on n'abordera pas
directement les questions européennes
aujourd'hui puisque nous avons le débat
demain que le ministre et participera
avec tout ça remonte l'occasion de
pousser les feux sur les questions
européennes
mais là le
le premier le premier grand dossier
c'est quand même dans dans la c'est
l'ouverture de l'administration byden
sur les instances multilatérales
on a évidemment après des années de
boycott de quasi boycott du
multilatéralisme pas l'administration
trump nous avons un grand retour mais un
retour keane qui n'est pas qui n'est pas
simple qui s'exerce sur le mc sur l'om
est sur l'otan sur sur l'onu de façon
générale donc un ensemble de choses tout
à fait
un gap l1 associé rival c'est à dire
quelqu'un avec lequel nous avons
beaucoup de choses à faire et en même
temps beaucoup de conflits potentiels
ce qui pose le problème de l' or c'est
pas une question européenne c'est une
question quand même beaucoup plus si nos
occidental ce qui pose le problème de
savoir comment nous accueillons le
dossier le traité qui a été conclue
conclu ébauché dans la conclusion a été
ébauché le traité sur les
investissements avec la chine
posons évidemment la question est ce
bien le moment
au moment où la chine dénonce le
pratiquement les accords qu'elle avait
conclu seront kong où elle engage aussi
hng kiang une politique extrêmement
inhumaine
est ce que il y as delà de la pertinence
à signer un traité qui effectivement
comprendre beaucoup davantage pour nous
mais en même temps qui repose sur une
disposition à appliquer les droits les
droits de la personne les droits humains
comme on dit maintenant qui n'est pas
évidente
nous avons troisième grand dossier iran
l'iran et l'arabie séoudite le couple
iran arabie saoudite où là encore
l'administration américaine une bouche
très fortement
nous voudrions avoir savoir ce que
comment vous appréciez ce mouvement sur
les deux les deux théâtre le théâtre
iranien et le théâtre et le théâtre
l'arabie saoudite ce qui est une forme
très important et troisièmement toujours
en lien avec le moyen-orient avec le
moyen-orient
le problème de la turquie nous avons eu
des tensions extrêmement vive avec la
turquie dans au cours des mois derniers
il semble que nous soyons engagés dans
une période de
de contact à nouveau plus serein mais
nous serons évidemment très très
sensible très intéressé par votre
analyse sur la dernière métamorphose de
monsieur erdogan le chef de gare a été
pro européen pour se détacher des états
unis il a été ensuite anti européen
quand les européens l'ont un peu trop
gêné dans la défense des droits de la
personne et s'est rapproché des états
unis il semble maintenant que la
relation avec les états unis soit moins
forte qu elle ne l était est donc une
sorte de mouvement nouveau vers l'union
européenne a encore c'est intéressant de
savoir comment nous l'apprécions enfin
d'une façon et ça nous avons les
problèmes de la démocratie en général
d'ailleurs se pose aussi en turquie
nous avons à tout un ensemble
deux situations extrêmement dur je le
détaillerai pas la russie la biélorussie
la birmanie la chine je l'évoquais et et
là quelle est notre attitude
comment devons-nous procédé nous faisons
confiance nous nous sommes nous semblons
être un peu abonné aux sanctions j'ai
été très frappée dans le dernier conseil
de l'avalanche de sanctions qui s'est
abattue sur tout le monde or j'ai
toujours un peu l'impression que de même
que herriot disait que la culture c'est
ce qui reste quand on a tout oublié les
sanctions c'est ce qui reste quand on
sait pas très bien quoi faire d'autre et
donc je crois que là il ya il ya un
problème est derrière cela il ya un
problème qui est posé par l'ensemble des
groupes et je crois qu'il faudrait y
être sensible c'est le problème de
l'extraterritorialité le
multilatéralisme c'est formidable
le la défense de la démocratie mais nous
ne voudrions pas continuer à être
associés à des mesures unilatérales que
nous n'aurions pas pris ce que nous
n'aurions pas cautionner et tous soyons
obligés d'avaler moi je suis de ceux qui
pensent que la souveraineté n'exclut pas
des liens très forts de caractère
multilatéral multilatérale et des liens
contraignant mais qu'en revanche elle
exclut totalement que année un état
indépendant soit soumis à une politique
qui n'est pas défini par lui ou avec lui
et c'est un peu ce qui se passe rien
risque à partir du moment où on met
l'accent sur les sanctions
on met l'accent sur la lutte pour la
démocratie de voir tout un ensemble de
mesures
cligny unilatéralement à washington et
auquel nous serions nous serions soumis
à voile à toutes les questions on
l'habille alors la birmanie je n'insiste
pas c'est la situation est très
préoccupante vous avez marque pris des
positions très très net là dessus vous
avez marqué votre votre la gravité que
vous l'importance que vous y attachez le
extrême préoccupation que vous inspirez
cette situation qui peut effectivement
dégénéré en un bain de sang assez
facilement
vous voyez monsieur monsieur le ministre
vraiment la cour est pleine
donc je vous passe je me tais je vous
pose toutes ces questions je ne sais pas
si vous n'aurez le temps de répondre à
tout mais en tout cas ce sont les
préoccupations que je crois chacun
rochât merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
devraient d'abord vous dire que moi
aussi je suis très très ému de ce qui
s'est passé cet après midi oui je vais
je vais y revenir je n'oublie jamais le
16 mai mais je suis je suis très ému de
ce vote de de la manière dont il a
abouti parce que finalement personne ne
se renie dans ce moto dans le travail en
commission d'une part et et en plénière
d'autre part je crois que les uns les
autres ont fait preuve de compréhension
si bien que nous avons un texte riche
mais très exigeant et l'unanimité qui
s'est manifestée abstention enfin le
l'esprit était hélas nous engage
mutuellement nous et puis les
gouvernements qui nous succéderont qui
ne sur un document qui fait peut-être
qui pourrait sembler une charte une
certaine manière n'a pas été facile à
mener à son terme
vous l'avez souligné les uns et les
autres ça n'a pas été facile de love le
faire inscrire ni d'obtenir les
financements nécessaires
mais là ça nous donne un souffle
considérable pour que nous revenions
dans le jeu du développement au niveau
international
mais ça nous engage aussi en tout cas à
nouveau je vous remercie du travail qui
a été fait que nous allons faire en
commun je vous avais dit monsieur le
président que nous allons voir plusieurs
fois dans les jours qui viennent puisque
demain il y aura un débat sur l'europe
et qu'après demain donc je vais pas en
parler maintenant si ça vous ennuie pas
puisque je serai amené à revenir demain
sur ce sujet et et d'autre part il y
aura après demain un débat sur nos
barkan
quelle quelle je participerai également
mais je veux quand même vous dire
quelques mots sur le sec je suis pas sûr
qu d'abord que tout le monde sera là
jeudi pour le débat sur barkan donc on a
un rendez vous par jour alors son nom et
ce n'est pas pour me déplaire
mais je voudrais quand même vous dire
quelques mots sur la situation au sahel
depuis qu'on ne s'est vu il s'est passé
comme même ce que je pourrais intitulé
comme une forme de ce dynamique de
sursaut civile que j'avais appelé de mes
voeux en particulier lors du débat sur
barkan qu'ils aient lieu au sénat ya
quelques semaines et qui s'est
manifestée de plusieurs manières
d'abord il y a eu la réunion de ce qu'on
appelle le comité de suivi de l'accord
d'alger
je vous rappelle que l'accord d'alger
des conclu en 2015 2015 est qu après de
nombreuses discussions qu'il intégrait
ce que l'on appelle désormais les
groupes armés signataires les autorités
maliennes
les nations unies l'algérie la france
pour un certain nombre d'acteurs de sur
l'ensemble sahéliens et pour toutes
sortes de raisons ils mettaient beaucoup
de difficultés à se réunir et surtout ne
se réunissait pas ils se réunissaient à
bamako mais jamais à kidal or là il y a
eu un événement auquel j'ai participé
une barre vision en raison de la
situation sanitaire
il s'est tenue à kidal donc je pense que
vous voyez où se trouve kidal au nord au
nord du mali pas loin de la frontière
algérienne en présence physique du
ministre algérien
on connaît de beaux cadeaux en présence
vision de ma part avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
c'est la première fois que c'est arrivé
et ça a été un événement qui s'est
traduit par un certain nombre de
décisions sur lesquelles je reviendrai
si vous si vous le souhaitez mais qui
reprennent les éléments fondamentaux de
désaccord d'alger qui n'ont jamais été
vraiment mobilisés par les autorités
politiques maliennes
or celle ci même si elles sont issues
d'un coup d'état veulent mettre en
oeuvre ces dispositions et donc du coup
ça a permis je crois un échange très
très significatif qui nous a permis les
uns et les autres d'intervenir dans
cette discussion et c'est un moment une
phase très très positif qui c'est qui
s'est manifestée de deuxième deuxième
élément depuis qu'on s'est vus cette
réunion de deux kidal et s'est tenue le
11 février
depuis qu'on ne s'est vu il ya eu aussi
le dans la semaine du 15 février à
djamena deux événements différents d'une
part la deuxième assemblée générale de
l'alliance elle où nous avons fait le
point sur l'avancement du sursaut de
stabilisation et développement que je
souhaite que l'on engage dans le cadre
de cette alliance je rappelle que
l'alliance elle s'est désormais plus de
25 que près de 30 partenaires de l'appui
au développement ray et de l'appui
d'abord la stabilisation puis au
développement pour l'ensemble des pays
du g5
c'est présidée par ma collègue espagnol
et cette alliance à elle gère
aujourd'hui 23 milliards de dollars qui
sont sur la table mobilisables par les
actions des uns et des autres autour de
900 projets dans des secteurs essentiels
que sont l'agriculture la sécurité
alimentaire l'éducation l'énergie la
gouvernance bref on est dans le cadre du
débat covial d'avoir à l'assemblée et 7
c était un point important parce que
j'ai voulu je souhaite que l'on puisse
faire en sorte que nous ayons un autre
modèle de développement dans la zone du
sahel en termes d'organisation et de
gouvernance pour qu'il y ait du
développement territorial
parce que trop souvent vous avez là je
ne sais combien d'acteurs dans les gg
parler de 25 partenaires médias de
l'intérieur des acteurs plurielle qui
souvent chacun sert des problèmes de la
politique de développement travaille sur
son projet dans son silo dans son
créneau sans s'occuper de ce qui se
passe à côté
et donc quand je dis ya énormément de
moyens financiers disponibles
oui mais quand on est dans telle partie
de l'huile du sahel il ya le tenu qu'il
fait quelque chose l'organe de
développement de l'allemagne qui fait
autre chose l'afd qui fait un troisième
show tout ça et qu il est correct mais
pas cohérent et donc la grande
orientation qui a été prise dans cette
réunion de l'alliance pour le sel c'est
de faire de la gestion territorialisée
du développement singulièrement dans les
zones où il y a eu il y avoue il ya eu
des situations conflictuelles ou le
travail de pacification doit se faire
par par le développement par l'aide
humanitaire immédiatement par la
stabilisation par le développement
c'est une grande avancée maintenant là
aussi il faut la mettre concrètement en
place sinon le cycle infernal reprendra
inévitablement vont pouvoir y revenir
dans la discussion mais ça a été un
événement dans le au cours de l'
alliance la réunion de l'alliance pour
le sahel
il y a eu aussi la décision de
s'accaparer le projet de grande muraille
verte projet initié par les africains il
ya maintenant une quinzaine d'années qui
a été repris par le présent dans le
public il y avait peu de temps et qui a
été repris par l'alliance celles qui
visent à développer ce grand projet qui
mettra du temps mais qui est un projet
très mobilisateur et qui permettra de
restaurer 100 milliards d'hectares
dégradée du sénégal à djibouti
d'ici 2030 en luttant contre la
désertification en protégeant la
biodiversité
donc c'est un engagement on pensait que
ce projet n'avait pu voir le jour il est
repris et maintenant il nous faudra
beaucoup de volonté pour le faire
aboutir enfin toujours dans le sahel
puisque le premier événement le la
réunion de l'accord d'alger deuxième
événement l'alliance pour le sahel et il
y a eu par ailleurs un sommet des pays
du g5
dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant la coalition internationale
pour le sahel puisque nous avons initié
au sommet de pau l'année dernière cette
coalition internationale pour celle qui
réunit 45 pays membres
depuis les européens jusqu'au japonais
en passant par toute une série d'acteurs
qui s'y engagent et ces échanges ont
permis d'une part de constater les
résultats de l'action qui avait été ici
à pau qui était de sorges militaire est
de faire en sorte qu'au brésil
progressivement on aboutisse à ce que la
sécurité dans les pays du sahel soit
assurée par les forces militaires
sahélienne elle-même et dans le cadre de
la force conjointe du g5
aujourd'hui j'en ai pas plus aujourd'hui
mais je suis pas sûr que dans le débat
qui se tiendra jeudi matin on a le temps
de parler aussi longuement de ce sujet
qui comme tout à fait central et que je
voulais et fauqué qui vont tellement
réponses auprès des questions sur ce
sujet alors vous avez parlé monsieur le
président 2
la nouvelle donne du fait de la nouvelle
administration américaine
je vais vous en deux jours on dire
quelques mots
depuis ce depuis son entrée en fonction
vous avez constaté vous l'avez dit que
le président byden a souhaité avancer
rapidement dans la mise en oeuvre de son
programme ne porte pas de d'observation
sur la politique intérieure américaine
mais je suis amené à parler de la
l'action internationale et autant le
dire là à l'heure actuelle les premiers
actes sont plutôt de bonne nouvelle
bonne nouvelle que le retour des
etats-unis dans l'accord de paris sur le
climat parce que c'est quand même une
échéance majeure de l'année 2000 21 qui
va se terminer par la com fences de
glasgow et qui nécessitera des
engagements indispensable des
contributions déterminée au niveau
national des cdn de la part des acteurs
de l'union européenne a déjà pris ses
propres engagements
mais il est indispensable pour que cette
coop soit décisive et que cette coop
puissent relayer l'accord de paris que
des engagements soient pris au niveau
des contributions des nouvelles
contributions des uns et les autres au
niveau de la finance climat pour que ce
soit des engagements au delà de 2025 et
enfin au niveau des règles de mise en
oeuvre de l'accord de paris liés au
marché carbone tout ça normalement c'est
l'agenda de glasgow sur lesquels
par ailleurs non seulement l'union
européenne est très engagé mais aussi le
royaume uni est là manifestement le fait
que les états unis reviennent dans
l'accord de paris les discussions que
j'ai pu avoir moi-même avec john kerry
sur la préparation de glasgow sont
plutôt encourageantes
bon maintenant on va attendre les rendez
vous le rendez-vous principal ça va être
le 22 avril puisque les états unis
organise un sommet sur le climat sommet
informel sur le climat qui est une
manière de revenir dans le dispositif de
l'accord de paris et c'est à ce moment
là qu'ils devront ils afficheront leurs
engagements bonne nouvelle de la levée
du veto américain à la nomination de la
nouvelle directrice de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce madame ngozi qui
niger yann qui étaient susceptibles
d'être retenus après une procédure de
candidature multilatérale qui avaient
été mises en oeuvre et donc tout cela ne
devrait permettre d'apaiser les tensions
commerciales actuelles on vous pourra
peut-être y revenir et permettra
d'engager une conception plus durable et
plus équitable des changements des
internationaux mais jusqu'à présent le
mca était en panne de tout on parle de
réformes panne de fonctionnement il
fallait les réformes et en plus elle
fonctionnait pas donc maintenant que ce
blocage est levé
on devrait pouvoir avancer dans un
chantier qui est quand même très très
lourd et très complète bonne nouvelle du
réengagement américain à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé
vous l'avez évoqué c'était quand même
ahurissant que les états unis ne soient
pas se soit retiré de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé au moment précis où
il y avait une pandémie jamais connues
dans le monde et que l' oms et jusqu'à
preuve du contraire la seule
organisation internationale qui puisse
agir dans la prévention sanitaire
bref bonne nouvelle aussi on n'en parle
pas beaucoup mais je tiens à le dire par
la prolongation d'une traité new start
avec la russie sur je l'avais évoqué ici
cette inquiétude puisque ceux de ce
traité devait tomber en février il a été
prolongé de cinq ans et cela met une
limite quantitative aux arsenaux
nucléaires stratégiques russes et
américains et donc c'est un élément il
faut prendre en considération puisque
depuis plusieurs depuis depuis quelques
années il y avait la disparition
quasiment systématique de tous les
accords multilatéraux qui pouvaient
exister dans le domaine militaire de non
seulement sur les errements du caire
mais sur les forces de défense
intermédiaire sur le ciel et donc nous
sommes dans un quelque chose qui se
passe sur sur deux sait et c'est du
lourd
puisqu'on est sur les armements
stratégiques et donc ça peut être un
élément d'encouragement pour travailler
sur la maîtrise des désarmements donc
tout cela c'est encourageant il y a une
volonté de rupture avec la précédente
administration et nous allons pouvoir
aller de l'avant ensemble en bâtissant
une nouvelle relation transatlantique
parce que ce que je vais vous dire mais
je crois l'avoir déjà dit ici l'europe
que d'administration hayden vient de
retrouver ce n'est pas l'europe d'il ya
quatre ans c'est une robe qui a commencé
à créer pour elle-même un agenda de
souveraineté
et un agenda de présence dans le monde
différent de celui qu'elle avait
auparavant se réveille européen il faut
le maintenir
ça n'a pas été de mon point de vue
qu'une simple parenthèse dans notre
histoire est d'ailleurs lorsque mon
nouvel homologue anthony blinken
et de ah était en débat avec l'ensemble
des ministres affaires étrangères des
vingt-sept il ya quelques jours
depuis washington en visioconférence il
a affiché très clairement qu'il est
l'intérêt des américains c'est plutôt
d'avoir un allié fort et énergie plutôt
que d'avoir un allié servile bon bah
prononça comme un déclaration importante
qui nous importe maintenant de décliner
dans différents domaines que nous allons
rencontrer alors vous avez évoqué
monsieur le président plusieurs sujets
liés à la suite je vais revenir sur
quelques uns de ces sujets qui n intègre
évidemment la nouvelle relation
transatlantique
d'abord sur l'iran comment dire
nous sommes dans une situation un peu
paradoxale où les etats-unis ont annoncé
leur volonté de revenir dans jcp moi je
reviens pas sur le contenu de ce que
c'est que j'ai super mal
j'y reviendrai dans les dents les
questions mais pas reprendre tout ils
l'ont annoncé à la suite d'une
discussion longue que nous avons eues à
quatre entre dominique grab le ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères et
comme à moi même et anthony blinken
il ya dix jours du 18 février
le lendemain il a été dit publiquement
que les états unis voulaient revenir
dans les cpe c'est à dire reprendre leur
place sous réserve que évidemment l'iran
revienne aussi sur ses engagements
initiaux qu'ils ont progressivement
rompu au fur à mesure des des mois après
le retrait américain de 2018
il ya d'une part et d'autre part pendant
le même temps on voit se développer
les tensions dans la zone est aussi les
ruptures d'autres ruptures de la part de
l'iran à l'égard de ses engagements du
gcp haut à la dernière étant
techniquement ça se dit le renoncement
au protocole additionnel du tnp
ça veut dire en bon français que l'iran
décidé de ne plus accepter les contrôles
de l'iowa d'une manière générale sur
l'ensemble de leurs activités et et que
c'était une rupture avec une autre
rupture avec des engagements de l'accord
de vienne donc tensions sur le nucléaire
qui va nous amener d'ailleurs nous dans
les jours qui viennent
émettre une protestation sur l'autoroute
dont le camp dans le cas du conseil des
gouverneurs de l'aiea pour regretter
cette prise de décision
deuxième élément il y à des tensions
dans la zone de nouvelles attaques des
aussi
sur l'arabie saoudite une attaque à
erbil sur des forces de la coalition
erbil kurdistan bon par des milices
associé à l'iran donc attention aussi
sur la circulation dans le golfe
et puis troisièmement le fait que à une
proposition que nous avions fait d'une
réunion de l'informel passe comme les
états unis ne sont pas dans l'accord ils
peuvent pas siéger dans une réunion de
l'accord puisqu'ils sont plus il faut
trouver le moyen de rentrer d'une
réunion informelle pour qu'on puisse en
débattre nous l'avions proposé et les
iraniens ne veulent pas pour l'instant y
participer donc nous sommes dans cette
situation compliquée je me suis
entretenu avec mon collègue iranien pour
essayer de montrer que l'intérêt était
de trouver les voies et moyens de retour
des uns et des autres une situation de
tension du même du même type que celle
que nous avions rencontrée à l'automne
2010 9 lorsque vous en souvenez au
moment du g7 de biarritz il y avait eu
tentative de d'accord qui avait failli
aboutir et qui n'a pas abouti la
différence quand même par rapport à la
situation jeudi sa très clairement
puisque je n'oublie pas que nous sommes
en séance ouverte à la presse la
différence dans cette situation de
tension à l'époque et de tension
maintenant c'est que à l'époque les
états unis avaient quitté l'egypte loi
est là nous sommes devant des états unis
qui veulent rentrer voilà où j'en suis
nous en sommes à l'heure actuelle et ses
deux il ya de l'actualité tous les jours
puisque le président république s'est
entretenu encore aujourd'hui avec le
président hu a nié puisque vous
m'interrogez sur le jcp voilà ce que je
peux dire c'est le traître est
complètement sûr en étant le
le plus libre possible avec vous dans le
cadre de la situation au moyen-orient
ce que l'on peut noter simplement sur la
situation irakienne en particulier c'est
une forte résurgence de dèche qui nous
amène à souhaiter avec des autorités
irakiennes
nous avons eu pendant toute la période
récente des relations très étroites avec
le premier ministre casimir nous amène à
souhaiter que ce qu'on appelle la
coalition contre des ch qui ne s'était
pas réunie depuis pas mal de temps
puisse se réunir à nouveau pour
renforcer la souveraineté et la
stabilité de l'irak qui reste fragilisée
par à la fois la résurgence de dèche
dans les zones sunnites et aussi par des
tensions régionales il pas compris par
l'action d'un certain nombre de milices
qui remettent en cause l'autorité du
premier quasiment y va y avoir des
élections je sais plus contenu très
bientôt en irak qui voudrait qu'on
puisse réunir cette coalition assez
rapidement et je pense que ça va se
faire
quelques mots sur je suis toujours sur
la nouvelle donne américaine
je ne loue pas la chine que j'ai je vais
y arriver monsieur le président je vois
qui est que je vais arriver aussi à la
chine en faut pas non plus mais sur sur
sur le proche orient et sur la relation
israël palestine
il y a eu des bouges et qu'il faut aussi
identifié c'est à dire que la nouvelle
administration américaine a déclaré être
favorable à la
principe des deux états la nouvelle
administration américaine a rappelé sur
une opposition aux actes unilatéraux y
compris en matière de colonisation
l'administration américaine nouvelle a
repris ses financements américains
allouera est la nouvelle administration
américaine a repris aussi l'aide
américaine bilatéral de l'autorité
palestinienne bon donc il ya des signes
là mais nous sommes encore dans un
contexte de nouveau nous avons tenté
dans la période intermédiaire avec mon
collègue jordaniens égyptiens et
allemands de reprendre des discussions
avec les israéliens n est pas ici nous
avons des discussions assez longue avec
monsieur escales nazis le ministre
israélien des affaires étrangères avec
mon collègue palestiniens aussi on peut
penser qu'on arrivera peut-être à mettre
en place un nouveau dispositif mais pour
l'instant c'est encore un peu à peu
prématuré même si notre volonté commune
a été affichée on n'a pas encore eu
l'occasion d'évoquer l'ensemble de ces
questions avec le
ministre blinken mais c'est des sujets
sur lesquels il faudra assez rapidement
se positionner essayer de trouver un
chemin dans ce sujet difficile mais en
sachant par ailleurs qu'il va y avoir
aussi la des élections en israël
et donc c'est une période très très
particulière et puis en plus il ya la
situation sanitaire sur la question de
la nouvelle relation transatlantique
il va falloir aussi que nous parlions
avec les américains de la manière dont
on travaille au sein de l'otan je vous
rappelle que nous avions engagé avec
l'allemagne mois de décembre dernier au
sommet de londres
une discussion après des déclarations
assez forte du président de la
république dont chacun se souvient une
discussion sur les grands défis auxquels
l'alliance est aujourd'hui confronté il
ya eu un rapport qui a été fait par un
groupe des sages et que auquel nous
avons indirectement contribué
il ya trois sujets trois défis qui vont
être posées quelle on n'a pas encore les
réponses mais qui font partie de la
définition du nouveau concept
stratégique de l'alliance qu'il faudra
mettre en oeuvre il y aura
une réunion un sommet de l'alliance
prochainement dans la date n'est pas
fixée mais elle va se tenir sûrement dès
que les conditions sanitaires nous
permettront de les tenir et sera préparé
par une première réunion de travail que
nous allons avoir à la fin du mois de
mars avec l'ensemble des ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'otan dont
évidemment l'américain avec trois sujets
d'abord le sujet de la cohésion entre
les alliés pour réaffirmer les
engagements et les valeurs que nous
avons en commun y compris face à des
comportements problématiques
suivez mon regard deux membres de
l'alliance et de ce fait nous nous
souhaitons aboutir à un code de conduite
de l'alliance tels que le rapport des
sages l'a proposé deuxième enjeu les
enjeux de mobilisation des européens au
sein de l'alliance a fait l'objet de
relation un peu conflictuelle au cours
de la l'administration trump et et 3e en
jeu l'identification des menaces et des
défis sécuritaires dont l'alliance doit
se prémunir doit adapter ses actions
qu'ils s'agissent de terrorisme des
nouvelles menaces cyber des actions de
la russie et de la réflexion collective
sur l'impact des défis posés par la
chine sur notre propre sécurité dont il
ya là un champ d'action sur lequel n'ont
pas commencé en encore agir mais où le
calendrier va venir vite
oui on est sorti de la mort cérébrale
mais puisqu'on met sur la table les
sujets et que on a une attention sur les
sujets que nous mettons sur la table de
la part de la nouvelle administration
américaine
alors sur la chine
c'est le président vous aviez évoqué le
fait que
la chine était éventuellement rival
savait que la définition de notre
relation à l'égard de la chine repose
sur un triptyque la chine est notre
partenaire d'une autre relation où la
relation d euros permet la nôtre
singulièrement c'est un partenaire c'est
un concurrent c'est un rival si les
trois en même temps et donc il faut
gérer cette situation particulière en
sachant que sur la relation entre la
chine et les états unis il y a
évidemment une tension assez forte et
nous n'entendons pas nous entrer dans la
logique d'une rivalité sino-américaine
nous mais nous n'entendons pas
évidemment nous positionner aussi en
écho distance des états unis la chine
nous sommes dans une logique je cite le
présent de la république dans une
intervention atlantique comme s'il y a
quelques jours il ne s'agit pas
seulement de trouver un équilibre entre
deux grandes puissances il s'agit aussi
de préserver la démocratie
donc nous avons avec la chine un
dialogue de deux franchises de fermeté
et d'exigence parce que nous avons trois
déclinaisons de concurrence de
partenariat de concurrencer et de haies
et de rivalité
ce qui veut dire que nous sommes avec la
chine est très exigeant sur les
pressions exercées sur l'opposition
démocratique de hong kong qui sont pas
supportables très exigeant sur les
pratiques injustifiable dont font état
les témoignages et documents qui nous
parviennent du sillon qui semble
indiquer un système de surveillance et
de répression à grande échelle et si il
y a eu l'accord dont vous fascine vous
faisiez que l'on faisait référence tout
à l'heure il intègre les trois
dimensions et y compris le
la référence aux engagements de l'oit et
que le pays que la chine doit respecter
et nous sommes qu'au début d'un
processus puisqu'il faudra ensuite que
le lac homicide le conseil entérine et
que le parlement européen en soit saisie
dont nous sommes pas la fin de
l'histoire mais nous ont posé les
problèmes de base de manière très claire
et nous aurons nous continuerons à
expliquer notre partenaire américain
dans le cadre du dialogue union
européenne états unis sur la chine que
nous devons continuer à avoir ce type de
relations avec la chine franchise
fermeté exigence parce qu' on aura
besoin de la chine ne serait ce que pour
[Musique]
la réunion de glasgow
sur l'ensemble des questions
environnementales
cet appareil est un partenaire sur
d'autres questions c'est un concurrent
sur les questions de droits de l'homme
c'est un rival systémique parce que nous
sommes pas du tout dans les options donc
il nous faut tenir en permanence le
triptyque que je viens d'évoquer
enfin pour terminer sur ce jeu est un
peu longue disette je suis désolé
dévouement et mis beaucoup de choses
j'ai président sur la table donc pour
pour terminer sur sur la relation avec
des états unis il y a tout le champ de
la discussion dans le économique que
nous devons maintenant ouvrir et en
particulier la désescalade tarifaire
réciproque que nous devons engager à la
fois sur l'acier l'aluminium à la foux
sur l'aéronautique à la fois sur la
taxation d'une du numérique même si les
engagements de représailles à notre taxe
sur les services numériques par la
précédente administration américaine
n'avait pas été appliquée et son suspens
de il n'empêche que il faudra bien
commencer par une bonne explication avec
l'administration maidana dessus et le
premier signal positif qui a été donné
c'est l'acceptation de la reprise des
négociations a lancé des oeufs en vue
d'un cadre multilatéral pour la
fiscalité du numérique c'était bloqué
c'est bien de se ré ouvrir donc c'est
plutôt là aussi un signe un signe plutôt
plutôt positif il faudra aussi sur ce
sujet trouver des compromis sur la
régulation des plateformes numériques et
avoir un dialogue plus structurée dans
sur la construction d'un cyber espace
sûr ouvert et neutre
vous m'avez je terminerai par cela vous
m'avez aussi interrogé sur russie
biélorussie birmanie tous les pays où il
ya des dérives et des violations des
principes de la démocratie et des droits
des droits de l'homme s'agissant la
russie les décisions qui ont été prises
depuis cet été par les autorités de ce
pays démontre une dérive autoritaire qui
est très grave il ya eu les tous les
différents développements de la sphère
navalni depuis son empoisonnement
jusqu'à sa condamnation
il ya eu les arrestations les
condamnations arbitraires de
manifestants de de manifestants une
journaliste et puis il ya eu récemment
l'expulsion de trois diplomates
européens pour des motifs injustifiés
dont nous continuons de demander la
libération immédiate de monsieur navalni
et par ailleurs nous nous agissons pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait des sanctions
qui soit promulguée au niveau européen
c'est pas rien les sanctions ce n'est
pas à auch et
qui nous comment dire c'est que nous
sécurise c'est des sanctions ça interdit
à ceux qui en sont bénéficiaires et de
voyager en europe dans l'union
européenne et et d'avoir accès à leurs
propres actifs s'ils sont placés dans
l'union européenne
c'est pas rien pour un certain nombre de
responsables à condition de de bien
identifier les responsables concernés
c'est ce que nous faisons pour pour la
russie c'est ce que nous faisons aussi
pour la biélorussie mais avant de dire
un mot de la biélorussie sur sur la
russie il n'empêche que malgré tout nous
devons essayer de garder une relation de
long terme avec la russie une garde et
des canaux de discussion
nous ne renoncerons pas cette ambition
parce que c'est notre voisin et que on a
même si c'est un comme on dit parfois un
voisin désagréable
parfois horripilant parfois
insupportable parfois contre tout à fait
condamnable c'est notre voisin
donc j'ai eu l'occasion de dire l'autre
jour je le redis ici
la russie ne va pas déménager donc il
faut essayer de trouver garder malgré
tout les liens qu'il faut tout en étant
très ferme sur les condamnations
d'actions telles que celles menées à
l'encontre de monsieur n'à vanier sur la
biélorussie vous aviez rencontré madame
chicanos caillage est aussi l'occasion
de la rencontrer manifestement le
durcissement se maintient nous n'avons
ne reconnaissons pas la légitimité de
monsieur loukachenko et nous soutenons
faire conforme fortement la mobilisation
démocratique qui se développent et nous
avons aussi à cet égard prix et des
sanctions assez forte qui vise
l'ensemble des dirigeants de
l'admnistration loukachenko et monsieur
lukashenko lui même et on pourrait même
élargir ses sanctions à d'autres
responsables biélorusses si la situation
venait à se détériorer et sur la
birmanie
puisque vous avez aussi fait état de
cette situation assez dramatique
après un mois après le coup d'état
commis par les forces armées le 1er
février
la situation continue à se dégrader il
ya eu un millier d'arrestations le
week-end dernier les menaces se
multiplient à l'encontre des
représentants élus en novembre dernier
le mouvement désobéissance civile vous
l'avez rappelé se poursuit le peuple
birman est extrêmement attaché à la
démocratie et nous avons là aussi initié
au niveau européen des sanctions
extrêmement strictes contre les
autorités militaires birmanes mais
surtout fait en sorte qu' il y ait un
mouvement international de protestation
à l'encontre de la junte militaire et en
soutien aux autorités élues s'est
manifesté non seulement par l'union
européenne mais par le g7 par le conseil
de sécurité des nations unies par le
conseil des droits de l'homme
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
s'est également mobilisée vendredi
dernier et nous avons agi auprès d'eux
en fin de semaine dernière
oui auprès de nos collègues malaisien et
indonésiens puisqu'il y avait une
réunion extraordinaire des mises
affaires étrangères de l'asian à jakarta
vendredi
si oui non sap en ce moment et qui
devrait prendre aider les pays concernés
à prendre des mesures et des actions
contre cette action insupportable menées
par la junte militaire
mais vous avez évoqué notre capacité
d'action et je terminerai par là nous
nous avons une gamme d'instruments face
aux violations des droits humains
nous avons d'abord la condamnation que
nous essayons d'avoir mené à 27
jusqu'aux sanctions en passant par les
canaux discrets que nous employons
lorsque les défenseurs des droits de
l'homme sont menacés jusqu'à l'accès à
notre marché que nous utilisons comme
levier de pression dont nous avons toute
la gamme de déclinaisons nous n'avons de
la force que si nous sommes 27
ça ne sert à rien de mener des sanctions
si on est tout seul mais à 27 c'est
totalement différent et c'est cette
logique là que nous défendons pour dans
le cadre du modèle européen qui doit
permettre d'agir sur les comportements
tout en ne renonçant pas à aider les
populations directement concernées
c'est à dire
lorsque l'on développe des aides ces
deux ronds revient sur le débat du
développement lorsqu'il ya une junte
militaire où des acteurs qui font des
coups d'état il ne faut pas qu'il y ait
la double peine pour les populations
concernées
donc il faut garder des actions
humanitaires autant que faire se peut
pour aider les peuples à se maintenir
dans la dignité
voilà m de manière un petit peu
patchwork le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés quelques éléments
d'actualité il y en a beaucoup d'autres
mais je suis tout à fait disposé à vous
répondre si je peux à différentes
questions
oui merci monsieur ministres
effectivement c'est certain c'est un
grand panorama que vous avez dressé
comme qui correspondait aux questions
que nous posons nous mêmes et que les
collègues vont continuer de vous poser
donc je serai sans tarder nous allons
engager le débat avec les représentants
les porte parole des groupes
et d'abord la parole sera à olga gilles
gernez pour la république en marche pas
chers collègues vous avez la parole mais
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre merci de cet exposé très riche
et précis nous comprenons que les
tensions internationales s'accentuent en
tout cas sont toujours présentes
même dans ce contexte géopolitique
particulièrement troublé par les
multiples crises issus de la pandémie
due qu'aux vide de lakovic 19
je tiens à saluer la mobilisation de
notre diplomatie qui malgré la crise
reste très présente
que ce soit au plan européen ou
international en atteste le vote à
l'unanimité il y à quelques minutes de
l'excellent projets de loi relatifs au
développement solidaire et dont nous
avons également longuement discuté dans
notre commission nous pouvons être fiers
de ce texte qui acte le retour en force
de la fraude france dans l'aide publique
au développement
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
le ministre ce vote est à l'honneur de
la france
car monsieur le ministre vous me
permettrait de revenir sur des
déclarations concernant la gestion par
l'union européenne de la crise sanitaire
en effet la présidente de la commission
ursula von der leyen a annoncé hier un
projet de passeport numérique vert il
s'agira semble-t-il d'un certificat
médical indiquant si on est vacciné
tester ou
possession d'anticorps il aura pour
objet de faciliter en toute sécurité une
circulation au sein de l'union
européenne et à l'étranger que ce soit
pour le travail ou le tourisme on se
souvient que lors du conseil des
ministres de janvier l'europe s'étaient
montrés divisés sur le sujet d'un côté
les états comme la grèce ou l'espagne
s'était montré très favorable aux
passeports vaccinale de l'autre
l'allemagne et surtout la france avaient
affiché leur réticence ces dernières
semaines grecs et chypriotes ont même
conclu un accord avec israël et
s'apprêterait à faire de même avec le
royaume-uni de pays hors union
européenne très avancées en matière de
vaccination
en parallèle le président de la
république appelle à tenir ensemble et
il a évoqué en fin de semaine dernière
des pistes pour la réouverture des lieux
publics notamment l'idée d'un pass
sanitaire qui doivent être précisées
alors monsieur le ministre ces solutions
de la vaste rediscuter évidemment par
les parlementaires mais serait-il
possible à d'avoir votre position à vous
même cette question est essentielle pour
la saison touristique mais plus près de
nous il ya aussi le calvaire des
frontaliers on a beaucoup parlé ces
derniers jours des 16000 mosellan pour
qui travailler en allemagne et devenu un
casse-tête en tant que député de l'ain
je voudrais aussi évoqué le bassin
genevois où la circulation entre la
france et la suisse a certes été aménagé
pour les professionnels et les résidents
dans un rayon de 30 km et ces règles ont
bien évidemment pris en compte la
réalité de ce bassin de vie cependant
nous sommes régulièrement saisi par les
familles dans le quotidien bouleversé
par les restrictions qu'il s'agisse de
garde d'enfants de petits enfants de feu
de deux visites en famille alors
monsieur le ministre tenir ensemble
est-ce que ça s'applique aussi avec nos
pays voisins
les quatre à six semaines comment vont
être appliquées pour le quotidien des
frontaliers je vous remercie avait dit
ma chère collègue qu'on n'abordait pas
les questions européennes
on a abordé un énorme panorama et ont
ont réussi à pénétrer sur des halles
domaine que nous n'avons pas abordé
on va aborder toutes ces questions
européennes demain dans le cadre du
débat monsieur herbillon pour pour les
républicains
je vous remercie monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais que
vous puissiez revenir sur la relation
avec les états unis
parce que vous indiquez un certain
nombre de bonnes nouvelles on s'en
réjouit il ya une autre attitude je
dirais qu'il ya surtout plus de
politesse et de civilité
on va dire ça comme cela par rapport aux
aux années trump mais est-ce que
derrière les mots derrière la tension
nouvelle derrière un certain nombre de
deux deux décisions que vous avez
rappelé notamment le retour vers le
multilatéralisme
qu'est-ce qui a pu vous dites l'europe
et plus exactement la même il ya un âge
date souveraineté de l'europe je
reprends vos terres mais le réveil
européen ça se traduit quoi comment
concrètement dans les relations avec les
états unis
concrètement est ce que vous dites que
pour les états unis ne trouve pas la
même europe mais l'europe ne retrouve
pas exactement et jouer bailon n'auront
pas exactement les mêmes états unis
parce qu'on peut pas simplement
considérer que les quatre années trump
n'existe pas la meilleure des preuves et
est donc là une notion d'america spurs
restent très prégnante la meilleure des
preuves c'est quand tony blinken dès
qu'il a pris ses fonctions a dit que ce
qu'avait fait tron sur la chine s'était
très bien et qu' il allait maintenir
cela est donc je voudrais que vous
alliez un peu plus loin parce que très
franchement comme on est entre nous on
peut vous dire on reste un peu sur notre
faim
tout en étant très grand intérêt à ce
que vous nous avez dit mais on reste un
peu sur notre faim parce que et on
voudrait que vous allez un petit peu
plus loin dans ce que vous attendez et
comment va se s'exercer concrètement
cette nouvelle relation transatlantique
au delà des principes et cette relation
avec les états unis et en particulier
j'évoque cette question qui a beaucoup
pénalisé les entreprises françaises vous
en souvenez quand les états unis et le
présenterai ce sont sortis de l'accord
du cpe et c'est les règles
d'extraterritorialité où les entreprises
françaises qui avaient déjà commencé
avec
et ce tir en iran ont été fortement
pénalisées donc je voudrais que vous
reveniez sur ce point et j'ai une
deuxième question à vous poser ses
concernant l'algérie alors je sais que
c'est toujours compliqué de parler de
relations entre la france et l'algérie
tellement ces relations sont marquées
par les brûlures de l'histoire et mais
on le mouvement irak reprend avec des
manifestations malgré la situation
sanitaire
le président tebboune a annoncé de
nouvelles élections législatives
mais on a le sentiment que la présence
de l'armée est toujours aussi forte et
que c'est elle qui détient le pouvoir en
vérité est que rien n'a vraiment changé
en algérie donc je voulais savoir
comment dans cette relation complexe
mais essentiel aussi pour la lutte
contre le terrorisme vous l'avait dit
entre la france et l'algérie comment
vous voyez l'évolution des choses
merci merci monsieur le député du
val-de-marne la parole la parole est à
monsieur bruno fuchs pour le modem merci
monsieur le président je vais revenir
sur le sommet du g 500 jimena qui s'est
tenue il ya une quinzaine de jours pour
essayer de refonder la stratégie de la
france avec nos partenaires stratégie
dans la région a c'est nécessaire car le
profil des groupes armés depuis 2012 a
beaucoup évolué en 2017 il la
constitution du groupe de soutien
l'islam et aux musulmans fusion de
différentes forces jadis de la région
sont maintenant des fédérations de
groupes armés qui s'organise et qui
s'étendent en périphérie de la zone
sahélienne en 2016 aqmi a revendiqué les
attaques en côte d'ivoire dans la cité
balnéaire de grand bassam 19 morts plus
récemment le poste frontière avec le
burkina fait l'objet d'une attaque qui a
coûté la vie à quatorze militaires je
serai ici saluer la mémoire de nos deux
combattants qui sont décédés au bénin a
lors d'une opération de libération
d'otages français en 2019
le sénégal pôle de stabilité dans la
région on devient aussi un terrain
d'intérêt pour les conglomérats
djihadiste le pouvoir indique multiplié
les arrestations d'individus liés aux
groupes terroristes
aastra frontière avec le mali
monsieur le ministre puisqu'on évoque
les questions de stratégie
n'est-il pas peut-être temps d'imaginer
une stratégie un peu audacieuse mais qui
résiderait à présent un redéploiement
géographique le fait que macky sall
président du sénégal et participer au
dernier sommet djamena pourrait-il
préfigurer un changement de stratégie
vers une prise en compte
un peu anticipée du jaune beaucoup plus
large qui est la zone de l'afrique de
l'ouest sur cette question deuxième
interrogation au sahel pour atteindre
ces objectifs la france a besoin de
partenaires de confiance sur la question
militaire mais une fois et vous l'avez
dit une fois que les territoires ont été
reconquis il faut y mettre un état fort
des services publics
un état qui protège la population or
force est de constater que certains de
nos partenaires contribuent grandement à
fragiliser leur pays au tchad idriss
deby va s'assurer un sixième mandat
après avoir réécrit la constitution à sa
faveur et avoir repris mais l'opposition
politique
pas plus tard que ce week-end opposant
yahia d'îlots de giroud a été victime de
tentatives d'arrestation qui s'est soldé
par l'assassinât de sa mère et de son
fils pour sa part succès se massera sera
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
contre la volonté du président deby qui
a cherché à l'écarter au niger la
contestation du résultat de l'élection
présentielle dernier s'est rendue muette
par des coupures internet de plus en
plus fréquentes au mali la france a
soutenu en son temps l'ancien chef
d'état ibrahim boubacar keïta qui a été
renversé et qui seraient coupables selon
plusieurs rapports indépendants de
détournement de fonds et de corruption à
grande échelle
alors si on parle du contenu du post du
postulat pardon que la france doit
renforcer et traiter des états forts
dans la région qu'est ce qu'un état fort
un état dont le régime est stable mais
qui feint de respecter la volonté
populaire en la piétinant ou est ce
plutôt un état dont le pluralisme et
l'état de droit est respecté et qui
associer les citoyens à sa construction
politique monsieur le ministre l'action
diplomatique de la france et de la
france ça elle ne sortait pas plus
efficace si elle se concentrait sur le
pluralisme politique défense des règles
démocratiques sur la protection des
populations et la création des
conditions
d'un débat public inclusif merci
monsieur le député maintenant pour le
groupe socialiste monsieur alain david
la parole est à vous monsieur le député
de la gironde merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur monsieur le ministre
je vous avait alerté le 2 février
dernier lors de la séance des questions
d'actualité sur la situation en birmanie
après le coup d'état militaire et
l'arrestation d'aung san suu kyi
la cheffe du gouvernement civil ainsi
que celle du président vide min de un
certain nombre de députés et de
responsables du du pays l'état d'urgence
avait été proclamé pour un an et des
généraux placés aux principaux postes
depuis la contestation populaire subi
une violente et sanglante répression
policière les arrestations d'opposants
se poursuivre
il y a quelques semaines nous avons j'ai
accueilli et avec le groupe d'amitié
france birmanie dont je suis le
président une délégation d'élus birman
avec lesquels les échanges avaient été
passionnant nous avons fin 2019 préparé
minutieusement un déplacement le
déplacement d'une délégation
parlementaire
mais la crise sanitaire nous a conduit à
reporter notre voyage nous avons
également participé
et j'ai également participé il y a
quelques jours au rassemblement de
protestation devant l'ambassade de
birmanie à paris aux côtés de la
communauté birmane en france et du
président des birmans de france et donc
je suis particulièrement préoccupé par
ce qui se passe là-bas d'autant qu'il y
ait également le la situation du peuple
rohingya ce qui est parquée
à la suite de l'évacuation du depuis la
birmanie par les militaires vers le
bangladesh de ce peuple rohingya ce pour
lesquelles
j'ai pu tenter en tant que président du
groupe d'amitié un certain nombre de
démarches à l'occasion d'un voyage à new
york
j'ai rencontré le secrétaire général de
l'onu avec lequel j'ai pu évoquer ce
problème est également le le
l'ambassadeur de chine représentant
permanent de la chine qui après une
discussion que nous avons eue entre les
membres du d'un groupe d'une délégation
s'était engagé à accompagner bien sûr le
retour des rohingya ce
vers l'heure vers leur pays d'origine
c'est à dire la birmanie le ministère
des affaires étrangères allemand a
convoqué hier l'ambassadeur de birmanie
à berlin le secrétaire général des
nations unies antonio gutierrez a appelé
à intensifier les réponses
internationales
pourriez vous nous indiquez monsieur le
ministre quel voix ferme la france
peut-elle porter face à cette
démonstration de force
quelles actions comptez vous mener afin
d'oeuvrer pour une paix durable en
birmanie et à ton notamment aussi
explorer un certain nombre de pistes et
en particulier le gel des avoirs d'un
certain homme jette de généraux de la
jeune tu le qui sont placés en france et
en europe
merci merci monsieur le député
maintenant en visio monsieur terrab pour
merci non pour ce que j'ai dit oui
merci monsieur le président et merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre exposé
je voudrais vous parler monsieur
ministre des français du monde les
français de l'étranger vous savez ils
sont 3 5 millions à travers le monde
ils représentent ce que nous appelons
nos ambassadeurs à travers la planète
qu'importe la france au coeur et ils
sont des des fervents soldats de notre
développement économique où ils le
peuvent ils ont conscience monsieur le
ministre de la gravité du moment et ils
ont conscience que le monde n'était pas
préparé et que la circulation des
variants actuelle du virus
elle se fait à travers les personnes qui
voyagent et cela monsieur le ministre je
le dis en saluant votre action parce que
je le sais vous avez oeuvré l'année
dernière et encore ces quelques jours
qui viennent de passer à faire en sorte
que les françaises et français
l'étranger ne soient pas considérés
comme des étrangers et que
il puisse revenir en france quand ils le
souhaitent
ma collègue guy vernet a parlé du
transfrontalier moi je vais vous parler
des français à travers le monde
certains sont tellement choquée d'avoir
était bloquée et d'avoir été empêché de
rentrer en france que ils en sont venus
à saisir le conseil d'état
les associations avec lesquelles j'avais
au quotidien à l'étranger comme l'union
des français de l'étranger
on est venu à saisir le conseil d'état
par rapport au décret qui a été pris le
30 janvier dernier qui impose des motifs
impérieux à toutes les personnes qui
veulent accéder au territoire national
et de nombreuses pétitions monsieur
ministre circule ces dernières semaines
pour rappeler que non que nos
compatriotes qui résident à l'étranger
ne sont ni des parias ni des français de
seconde zone
et malgré la longueur monsieur ministre
et je sais que vous y avez oeuvré
personnellement malgré la longueur des
motifs impérieux pouvant leur permettre
d'accéder au territoire national
beaucoup de motifs n'y figure pas je
vous donne des exemples comme par
exemple si on a un problème chez soi et
qu'on doit rentrer en france ça n'est
pas possible
6e on a des questions de succession pas
rentable des choses comme ça beaucoup de
nos compatriotes se sont vu refuser
l'embarquement monsieur le ministre et
et ça c'est absolument scandaleux et
aujourd'hui nos compatriotes qui
résident à l'étranger ont le sentiment
qu'ils sont mal traités le sénégal vous
prendre un exemple des français qui
résident sénégal qui aujourd'hui n'a
connu que 880 décès 8 181 décès du co
vide
comment peut-on excusez moi
vous m'avez je suis ça a coupé
pardonnez-moi e le sénégal qui a connu 8
181 décès comparé à des pays comme la
france comme d'autres pays où il ya 80
milles plus de 80
mille personnes qui sont décédées de
l'aco vide que des français qui résident
au sénégal ne puissent pas accéder au
territoire national alors que des
français qui réside en italie où il ya
des milliers de morts puisse y avoir
accès facilement vous comprenez qu'ils
estiment qu'il ya là un deux poids deux
mesures qui était acceptable alors la
question monsieur le ministre c'est
juste j'espère que vous allez porter
cela auprès du gouvernement
c'est est ce qu'on peut pas imaginer un
droit un droit inaliénable un droit aux
françaises et aux français qui résident
à l'étranger de pouvoir accès aux abords
de pouvoir accéder au territoire
national sans jamais être empêchés merci
monsieur ministre bonjour je vous
remercie monsieur meyer habib pour eu
des indépendants merci chers présidents
tous mes voeux de succès vous ac je ne
peux pas avoir une pensée pour marielle
qui qui nous manquait la première fois
où je prends en présentiel la parole en
commission des affaires étrangères sans
elle et je voulais avoir une pensée pour
elle et tout mais vous accompagne
monsieur le ministre
trois sujets rapidement un la turquie
vous n'avez pas on n'a pas eu le voilà
alors je sais que le président de la
république doit parler ce soir au
président erdogan après les dérapages
invraisemblable en particulier sur la
santé mentale de notre président
j'espère que les choses vont s'apaiser
député des français turquie peut-être un
mot pause entendre là dessus la deuxième
question c'est l'iran vous en avez
parler monsieur le ministre je voudrais
rappeler vos propos très lucide au dans
le jdd du 17 janvier vous dit jean yves
le drian
il est urgent de dire que cela suffit
l'iran joue site le je le dis clairement
est en train de se doter de l'armé
nucléaire
vous avez tout dit monsieur ministre et
ce qui est intéressant c'est que la
nouvelle administration américaine fait
que les masques vont tomber parce
qu'avant il se réfugie en ondes et
expliquant que c'était de la faute de
trump qui était sorti et c'est là
manifestement les américains je pense
que byden n'est pas obama
les frappes même si jamais c'était des
frappes légère il ya quelques jours ne
sont pas anodines et la question que je
voulais
le on sait que vous connaissez ma
position on a parlé à tellement de
reprise l'iran est un et 1 et 1 on
parlait des violations des droits
humains
le champion des violations des droits du
maine homophobes cruel islamistes etc
mais en plus ils risquent d'avoir l'armé
nucléaire
qu'est ce qu'on fait monsieur le
ministre les sanctions j'espère que ça
suffira peut-être pas et s'il ya pas de
sanction le pis le pire enfin je connais
bien les israéliens
s'il a pas si jamais il avance la
nucléaire ils s'éteindront c'est une
très mauvaise ce sera une très mauvaise
solution
donc la question que je vous pose quelle
quelle est votre intime conviction est
ce que vous pensez qu'on va y arriver
par rapport au fait il ya la seule
action que c'est est ce que oui ou non
ils seront nucléaire voilà le la
troisième question parce que le temps
est compté
ça a été abordée par deux mes collègues
c'est la question du passeport vert
j'écris le 15 février au président de la
république et je vous envoyer la copie
pour demander de dupliquer justement la
corde on parlait d'ailleurs ma collègue
le gage du vernet entre qui existe entre
qui a été passé entre les israël et la
grèce et la chine qui sont deux pays
mais cette constitution
pourquoi je dis ça parce que le mini
j'en avais parlé un excellent ministre
jean baptiste lemoyne qui n'était pas
tout à fait pour il y en a parlé de
discrimination
ce n'est pas une discrimination j'ai
demandé au premier ministre daniar
oussenov était d'accord de dupliquer cet
accord à moyen terme avec la france il
m'a dit oui je serais d'accord à
condition évidemment qu'il soit
réciproque
c'est à dire quoi c'est à dire que les
personnes vaccinées puissent voyager
avec un test pcr sans avoir de 70 avoir
deux semaines de confinement c'est très
important pour les français de
l'étranger pour les français habitant en
afrique du nord aux états unis etc
il faut encourager la population à se
faire vacciner
le vaccin c'est notre seul espoir et ça
marche ça marche même très bien en
israël en l'occurrence aujourd'hui on
ouvre les restaurants imaginez vous les
stades ça y est c'est alors on va y
arriver on a un peu de retard fait
beaucoup de retard j'espère qu'on va y
arriver
et donc ma question je vous ai envoyé
est ce que vous
vous seriez d'accord à dupliquer la ccl
accord entre pays avec un passeport vert
c'est une question qui préoccupe
beaucoup de français merci monsieur le
président d'avoir été un tout petit peu
long oui non l'inversé c'est un triomphe
à ce que effectivement grâce à vous la
question du passeport qui avaient été
posées par madame du vernet j'avais
réagi un petit peu vivement qu'on excuse
pas chers collègues va pouvoir recevoir
une réponse
donc de toute manière vous allez de ce
point de vue là c'est la parole et à la
parole et à monsieur mélenchon la parole
est un monsieur mélenchon merci
président merci monsieur le ministre
pour le tableau de situation que vous
nous avez fait le temps dont je dispose
je ne permets pas de vous faire
connaître les raisons de mon opposition
à vos appréciations aussi bien sûr la
russie que la chine et je vais donc en
rester à ce qui est pour nous le danger
le plus imminent est le plus préoccupant
puisque nous sommes directement impliqué
c'est à dire la situation au sahel
non pour l'envisager dans toutes ses
dimensions là encore le temps manque
mais pour me concentrer sur l'urgence je
ne partage pas votre enthousiasme pour
l'accord d'alger et donc pour la réunion
de deux kidal la vérité que l'accord
d'alger est rejetée par les autorités de
fait malienne actuelle comme par les
responsables de l'opposition qui s'était
exprimé dans les grands mouvements de
mobilisation populaire qui ont renversé
le précédent président de la république
la situation est extrêmement instable et
c'est dans ce contexte d'instabilité que
premièrement je veux mallarmé du risques
d'élargissement de la zone
d'autant que certains de mes collègues
qui ont appelé et que vos ma part j'y
vois surtout une source de danger et
d'extension des dangers qui pourraient
nous menace et si on ouvrait sans fin la
zone dans laquelle
les rapports de forces militaires ont
lieu aujourd'hui c'est évidemment je le
dis en référence à la forme qu'a pris le
g5 et puisque je parle du g5
alors j'en viens à l'environnement de ce
g salle qui était précédé par un très
grand nombre de manifestations
populaires qui est extrêmement intense
extrêmement dense contre l'annoncé par
le maréchal président idriss déby du
fait qu' il briguerait un sixième mandat
après plus de trente ans de présence à
la présidence on sait que ce qu'il en
coûte de soutenir au delà du raisonnable
des gens qui ne sont plus soutenables et
je pense que c'est le cas du maréchal
président en attendant les derniers
événements de samedi on montrait qu' il
était entré dans une logique que je
qualifierais mois de folle mais
tellement conforme à ce qu'il en est la
garde présidentielle dirigée par son
fils a pris d'assaut le domicile de
monsieur d'îlots l'un des ses opposants
et il en est résulté cinq morts dont les
plus la mère de monsieur d'îlots ainsi
que son fils pour ne rien dire des trois
autres qui méritent tout autant notre
attention
dans ce contexte et compte tenu de
l'environnement et du danger que cela
représente
le secrétaire général de l'onu a fait
connaître sa condamnation et sa
préoccupation
peut-être ai-je mal suivi monsieur le
ministre la france at elle dit quelque
chose
et dans ce cas quoi on a envie de vous
entendre sur le sujet peut-être en tout
cas quand je suis arrivé ici j'en étais
pas encore informé il est vrai que
j'étais dans l'hémicycle monsieur débit
n'est pas un facteur de stabilité
c'est un facteur de déstabilisation dans
la zone et qu'elle sera donc notre
attitude car monsieur le ministre vous
savez aussi bien que moi que
l'opposition à laquelle ils s'affrontent
n'est pas superficiel que ce n'est pas
juste un règlement de compte ou une
divergence politique ou politicienne
comme on peut en trouver ailleurs
il s'agit d'un reniement de fonds de la
société tchadienne que feront les
français et j'estime mois que notre
devoir est de multiplier les signes qui
nous permettent d'être compris par le
peuple tchadien
plutôt que par monsieur idriss deby qui
s'achève je suis dans mon épure non à
peine trop loin
me joindre à la demande qui a été faite
concernant la politique de la france à
l'égard d'héroïne ja et de la population
musulmane de birmanie réprimer des
portes et massacrer sans que la
communauté internationale manifeste à ce
sujet le même degré de préoccupation
qu'elle le fait dans des cas similaires
dans d'autres pays
je vous remercie le dernier intervenant
pour les groupes c'est monsieur jean
paul lecoq en vision pour évidemment la
gauche démocrate et républicaine
monsieur le député du havre vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président c'est pas si
vous me voyez aux visions j'aurai dans
le stand de bruits muscler ses cadres
exactement bien monsieur le ministre
demain se tiendront trois jours de
discussion en ligne pour se tenir et
faire avancer le document final de
processus de limitation de l'usagé des
armes explosives en zones peuplées ti
processus dit eh oui pas ces
négociations internationales historiques
vont permettre de faire progresser
l'application du droit humanitaire
ce dont les que deux députés communistes
se réjouissent très fortement
le texte doit permettre d'avancer sur
trois piliers fondamentaux
premièrement usage des armes explosives
lourde et imprécise dans le contexte du
combat urbain devra être drastiquement
limités deuxièmement il sera reconnu
officiellement par les états parties
qu'il existe des effets indirects à long
terme des bombardements aux zones
peuplées la destruction des
infrastructures comme les hôpitaux des
écoles et routes les réseaux électriques
et les réseaux d'eau les réseaux
d'assainissement éloigne durablement les
habitants de ces zones entraînant des
déplacements de population massifs et
une insécurité sanitaires sociales
économiques et environnementales
profonde et troisièmement il s'agira
d'améliorer l'assistance aux victimes en
créant un devoir de réparation des états
ce qui est par ailleurs un objectif
prioritaire du droit humanitaire
monsieur le ministre le texte actuel est
le fruit d'un consensus qui l'a affaibli
notamment sur le fait de l' usage d'un
verbe seulement le verbe pouvoir qui est
inséré un peu partout et qui entraîne
une atténuation des accusations portées
dans le texte contre les armes utilisées
en zone pop et on passe par exemple de
les armes
entraîne tel ou tel est fait par les
armes peuvent entraîner tel ou tel effet
malheureusement nous savons que la
france est du côté de ceux qui veulent
ajouter ce verbe pouvoir ainsi où vous
opposer à toute limitation sérieuse de
l'usagé des armes explosives les plus
lourdes et imprécise dans les zones
peuplées
vous êtes sur une ligne plus proche de
celle des états unis que de celle par
exemple du secrétaire général de l'onu
du cicr ou des ong comme handicap
international et nous le regrettons
amèrement
alors monsieur le ministre je vous le
demande au nom de mes deux cent dix
collègues parlementaires français et
allemands qui vous ont envoyé hier une
lettre ouverte
est ce que la france ont de se battre
pour faire que ce texte un outil pour
faire de ce texte un outil efficace pour
protéger les civils face aux
bombardements urbain en reconnaissant
les conséquences disproportionnées de
ces armes et non le seul usage
indiscriminée la france va-t-elle enfin
s'engager pour renforcer le premier
pilier de ce texte qui porte sur
l'anneau le non usage quand tu es à
terme des armes explosives en zone pop
et et enfin dernière question comment
réagir comment réagit le secteur de
l'armement français face à ce processus
diplomatique que je suis le quai d'orsay
fait-il partie de ceux qui veulent
limiter l'impact de ces négociations ou
apportez vous face à eux le fait que la
france souhaite il n'y a plus du tout
usage explosive de cette nature aux
zones peuplées
merci à vous tous merci merci monsieur
le député monsieur le ministre vous avez
la parole pour répondre groupe
je tiens à dire que j'ai un très très
grand nombre de parlementaires qui
demande la parole on passera en face en
2d je ne pense pas que tout le monde
pour avoir la parole mais pour l'instant
la parole est aux ministres qui va
répondre aux différents groupes
j'ai une vingtaine de une vingtaine de
parlementaires qui ont demandé la parole
à titre individuel ce qui prouve
l'intérêt que suscite ce débat pour ea
si vous revenez la semaine prochaine
c'est tout à fait tout à fait
souhaitable
allez-y en tout cas répondait au groupe
et ensuite on arrête à 20h30 est ce que
prix à 20 ans du g prévoit généralement
deux heures et demie mais bon
j'ai un bon challenge désolé de là mais
je comprends très bien parfois je sais
pas changé donc c'est extrêmement
généreux déjà de votre part de votre
temps donc on arrête on arrête à 20h30
je vous dois être à 20h vous partez
amateurs trop tout vous devez être
ailleurs attendant on a on a pour la
valeur seront réalisés en dehors on n'a
pas le temps de faire 20 questions non
non tu répondras kpatcha la réponse
alors madame j'hibernais et sur la
question puis ça concerne aussi monsieur
habib sur la question du passeport
sanitaires nous nous sommes intéressés
par le sujet du passeport sanitaire tout
en étant prudent pour l'instant parce
que il faut d'abord que l'appel la
proche soit résolument européenne
puisqu'il s'agit de d'envisager la mise
en place d'un document ayant un impact
sur la libre circulation au sein de
l'union européenne donc il ya eu un
mandat qui avait été donné à la
présidente de la commission européenne
qui a annoncé que la commission
proposerait un projet de législation sur
un passeport vers électronique pour
voyager plus librement
donc le concept est opportun il est
européen
il faut poursuivre les travaux sur les
enjeux techniques qu'ils sont il faudra
donc une preuve de vaccination
européenne qui ne n'est pas encore tout
à fait conclusive dans les préparations
et il faut aussi poursuivre les travaux
sur les enjeux de sécurisation de et de
protection des données personnelles sur
la mise en place d'un dispositif
similaire de résultats de tests et donc
il y a aussi des aspects éthiques qui
sont à prendre en considération puisque
si le passeport vaccinale
peu se délivrer que ce pour ceux qui ont
eu le vaccin tel ou tel moment ça reste
difficile d'avoir deux catégories de
population à un même moment et en
particulier les jeunes qui pourraient
pas en bénéficier donc il ya ce travail
de réflexion où c'est pas une opposition
c'est un travail de réflexion
approfondie
il ya aussi le fait que dans l'état
actuel de nos informations tout cas je
n'ai pas d'autres informations
il n'est pas encore démontré que le
vaccin immunise les autres et donc
ça vous immunise vous mais est ce que ça
ne le vaccin n'est pas automatiquement
ce n'est pas encore prouvée ne permet
pas une immunité totale externe
donc nous sommes dans ce travail là ce
n'est pas le même sujet que le pass
sanitaire que le président a rappelé
qu'à envisager au niveau national nous
préparons aussi cette ce dispositif qui
permet de d'avoir un titre national un
dispositif permettant pour un pouvant
permettre la réouverture de lieu de
rencontre et de structures potentielles
donc ces deux sujets sont
complémentaires cohérent mais nécessite
de poursuivre le haut niveau européen et
au niveau national les meilleures
garanties
parce que autrement il peut y avoir des
dérives qui soit à la fois éthiques et
juridiques et voir sociétaux qui serait
perturbant qu'il ferait que rajouter aux
difficultés que nous rencontrons
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur cette
question des passeports
j'en profite pour vous parler des de la
question de monsieur qui m'intéressait
monsieur le garage qui m'a interrogé sur
les frontières puisque le sujet est lié
que ça fait partie des enjeux européens
parce que madame je suis vernet vous
m'avez aussi interrogé sur le
les relations entre l'âme aux allées et
l'allemagne jouera je rappelle les faits
les choses situations qui sont
difficiles je le dis monsieur el guerrab
nous avons fermé les frontières
extérieures à l'espace européen de
l'espace européen ans au mois de mars
2020 c'est-à-dire au mois de baab depuis
le mois de mars 2020 normalement sauf
raisons impérieuses l'indispensable sauf
exception on ne rentre plus on ne sort
plus de l'espace européen quand on est
étranger
et que pour les étrangers à l'espace
européen et pour les français ou les
européens résidant en europe ce droit
s'applique est le seul loi ne
s'appliquait pas
donc il pouvait venir librement chez eux
à leur domicile mais la frontière était
fermé pour les étrangers à l'espace
européen sauf des motifs dûment
justifiés plutôt qu'au motif impérieux
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce moment là c'était
des motifs du vent justifie maintenant
c'est fermé pour tout le monde sauf
jeudi à monsieur el guerrab à tout le
monde ici sauf motif impérieux pour les
français qui reviennent sur dans leur
pays et motifs impérieux c'est vrai que
c'est une liste et c'est vrai qu'on
traverse est vraiment difficile et c'est
vrai monsieur el guerrab que malgré
votre souhait on ne peut pas faire une
classification par pays est autorisé au
sénégal où dans d'autres pays
parce qu'il ya ici un ratio qui est plus
favorable qu'un autre on ne s'en
sortirait pas donc je conçois que soit
très difficile pour nos compatriotes
j'espère que ça va pas durer trop
longtemps et que chacun doit bien
comprendre les motifs impérieux
autrement s'en sort pas et c'est cette
décision a été mise en place depuis la
mi- la mi janvier en raison de la
recrudescence du virus et surtout de
l'arrivée des variants donc nous sommes
pas les seuls à agir comme ça et sur
l'espace intérieur européen
les frontières ne sont pas fermées mais
on a renforcé depuis cette date là les
contrôles et la limitation des échanges
nous avions jusqu'à présent évité que
les frontaliers soit
inclus dans le dispositif de contrôle et
d'exigence de tests pcr de moins de 72
heures pour passer d'un pays à l'autre
dans l'espace européen
mais la recrudescence de la pandémie
dans certains secteurs a amené renforcer
les contraintes et singulièrement la
tête entre la moselle et l'allemagne
même si la frontière n'est pas fermée
que les contrôles se font de manière
aléatoire à l'extérieur mais de papa au
poste frontière
et s'il faut présenter un test de 63 72
heures 48 heures avec en plus de
l'autorisation d'utiliser les tests
antigénique donc c'est une ouverture un
peu plus grande on peut continuer à
circuler mais effectivement ça crée des
tensions et des embouteillages
oui et oui comme nous sommes dans une
situation pandémique très difficile et
il faut nous ne sommes pas non plus dans
par rapport à aux dispositions qui ont
été prises par l'allemagne
ils ont une position beaucoup plus ferme
beaucoup plus dur à l'égard de la
république tchèque est du tyrol que dans
la relation de voisinage avec avec la
france donc voilà je répond pas
positivement monsieur le grade mais je
comprends les contraintes que nos
compatriotes peuvent rencontrer
mais nous sommes dans une situation
sanitaire exceptionnel et ça exige de la
part de tous des des contraintes et des
sacrifices et le respect des motifs
impérieux qui sont nombreux mais
d'autres motifs qui sont pas impériaux
nous permet permettre d'attendre je suis
pas automatiquement porteur de bonnes
nouvelles je
j'en suis conscient mais il faut que
nous soyons responsables dans toutes ces
affaires alors
monsieur herbillon la difficulté dans
l'exercice qui est le mien c'est que
vous avez raison de souhaiter que
l'audition soit public mais que sur un
certain de sujets je suis extrêmement
sobre dans le propos moi je ne vois pas
d'inconvénient à ce que l'audition ne
soient pas publics mais même et donc sur
l'algérie moi je constate avec vous le
maintien des manifestations en
particulier dans le l'anniversaire de du
mouvement irak
je vous redis que nous sommes nous
suivons la situation de très près mais
en respectant la souveraineté de ce pays
ami nous avons bien pris note que le
président tebboune avec lequel le
président va qu'on s'est entretenu il ya
quelques jours est revenu de ses soins
et qui se
pour lui la copie d derrière lui qu'il a
engagé un ensemble de réformes qu'il a
engagées une amnistie décidée à la
veille du deuxième anniversaire du début
du rac qu'il a dans lesquels il y a eu
la libération du journaliste tahar et
nick que sur lesquels nous nous étions
battus beaucoup publiquement nous avons
dit ce que nous voulions dire sur ce
sujet je constate aussi qu'il a engagées
il a exprimé l'ambition de réformer
l'algérie en profondeur dans un esprit
de dialogue et d'ouverture
mais c'est aux algériens et à eux seuls
de déterminer la voie de leur avenir par
un dialogue démocratique dont il leur
revient de fixer les modalités
il ya eu ces démarches d'amnesty il ya
eu cette annonce de dissolution de
l'assemblée algérienne
cette volonté de réconciliation
maintenant c'est au peuple algérien
d'agir comme
il le sent dans le cadre d'un processus
démocratique que le président seebun
annonce vouloir renforcer
en tout cas c'est l'état des discussions
et qui des entretiens qui ont eu lieu
entre le présenter boon et le président
macron il ya quelques jours au retour de
présenter le boudin à alger il y aura
une réunion du comité de haut niveau
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle je crois
non c'est comme il était interné servi
au niveau entre l'algérie et la france
qui devait se tenir déjà depuis un
certain temps mais la maladie de du
président tebboune l'empêché donc il va
se tenir normalement assez assez
rapidement maintenant mais la date n'est
pas encore fixée
alors sur monsieur herbillon sur sur le
sur le reste
bon d'abord l'administration américaine
n'est là que depuis un mois j'ai dit que
les premières décisions étaient étaient
bonnes et est juste mais il faut
attendre sur l'eau sur le reste d'autres
d'autres actions il va y avoir des
rendez-vous significatif
j'en ai évoqué un qui est celui des
négociations commerciales et quand je
disais que l'europe a changé l'europe a
changé aussi là dessus parce que
l'europe a mis des contraintes
commerciales à l'égard des états unis
lorsque ceux ci ont voulu faire jouer
l'extraterritorialité en particulier
nous avons riposté
donc nous allons avoir un discussions
j'ai cité les trois les trois sujets
majeurs qui sont là devant nous sur le
dispositif acier aluminium d'une part
vous souvenez qu'on avait réagi par le
dispositif dit qu'on appelait moto x qui
goûte aux motos bourbon d'erreurs en
échange moto bourbon c'était des
comment s'appellent ces motos harley
davidson
donc on avait réagi en taxant les harley
davidson et le bourbon en retour
entendez ça faisait partie des
dispositions c'est pour ça qu'on appelle
le la riposte la riposte oui la riposte
boto bourbon voilà mais bon c'est trois
sujets là assis aluminium numérique et
aéronautiques
c'est des rendez vous majeurs
d'autant plus que parallèlement à ça ira
et ne j'espère le lancement de la
réforme de l'om c est maintenant qu il y
a l'autorité qui ont été reconnus et sur
l'extraterritorialité il faut poser le
problème
oui bien sûr de manière plus claire et
la différence par rapport à il ya quatre
ans c'est que l'europe est plus forte
qu'elle est moins naïve et qu'elle prend
position ferme comme ses intérêts sont
en jeu
elle a plus conscience on l'a déjà fait
depuis quatre ans à plusieurs reprises
il faut maintenir cet esprit et ce qui
ce qui a été dit dans la réunion que
nous avons eue avec eux le secrétaire
blinken l'autre jour aller dans ce sens
et la réponse était plutôt positive
plutôt compréhensive de cette situation
l'élève mais ceci étant les etats-unis
aussi ont changé il ya une situation
intérieure particulière il y a des
contraintes de politique intérieure qui
vont jouer sur la politique extérieure
inévitablement que sur la question
chinoise sur la question iranienne
inévitablement mais il faut que nous
mettions nous mêmes sur la table dans le
cadre de la reprise des discussions
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis
l'ensemble de ces sujets on aura aussi à
remettre sur la table les discussions
sur la sécurité je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure rapidement sur les trois thèmes
qui nous devons aborder dans la cadre de
la nouvelle relation transatlantique
nous nous sommes très déterminés là
dessus la bonne question c'est est-ce
que
les vingt-sept seront unanimes et
solidaire dans tout ça pour l'instant
oui il ya des prises de position de la
gauche américaine de la presse
américaine les partis qui sont quand
même très doux et très doux vers la
nouvelle se trouve je trouve bon alors
ça fait un mois c'est bon mais en tout
cas je voulais merci de ces questions
parce qu'il y avait deux étaient
importantes
alors je sais pas si je prends bien dans
l'ordre monsieur monsieur fuchs il ya
beaucoup de choses sur l'afrique
oui ben moi j'ai un désaccord avec
monsieur mélenchon ce qui ce nom mais
sur un point précis non mais je vais je
parle et je me bats cieux mais un jour
je parle assez souvent avec monsieur
fuchs moise avec vous s'il fut un temps
où je parlais beaucoup avec vous bien
longtemps ya longtemps mais bien mais
bon je vous n'avez il faudra reprendre
ça allait l'autre c'est un cc voit on a
pris de l'âge depuis mais ça n'empêche
pas de ça n'empêche pas les souvenirs
savez le jardin de l'ambassadeur à
l'ambassade de l'île maurice je vous
rappellerai sage moi aussi je vous dis
ça parce que j'y suis retourné l'autre
jour mais
quand je n'ai pas entendu la même je
n'ai pas entendu la même chose que vous
pas au revoir au revoir mais ça ça sera
notre sujet et danse yeux sur les mais
c'est la première fois que jean monsieur
mélenchon et de mes auditions donc jeu
en trois ans et demi je suis très
honorée que monsieur mélenchon me fasse
le plaisir de venir m'écouter s'était
jamais arrivé depuis que demi depuis
vous m'avez écouté aussi voilà alors
alors je donc d'abord monsieur mélenchon
à kidal
il y avait six membres du gouvernement
du mali donc vous disiez dans vos propos
tout à l'heure que c'était pas la
volonté du gouvernement intérimaire si
il était là il était tout ce qu'il
fallait ce qu'ils soient là était là et
donc cette démarche là elles se
développent et je m'en réjouis
ce que nous demandons aux autorités
maliennes aujourd'hui c'est de respecter
le calendrier sur lequel ils se sont
engagés à l'égard des membres de la
cedeao et donc
c'est à dire que les élections le
processus électoral devrait avoir lieu
maintenant 14 world dont je me souvienne
nous est rendu à 14 mois et c'est ce
qu'il faut qu'il respecte mais là
l'initiative qui a été prise et les
accords d'alger sont de bons accords
il faut simplement les respecter ils
prévoient le développement du nord il
prévoit l'intégration des groupes armés
dans l'allée force les forces maliennes
donc tout ça et est tout à fait clair
sur le jeu reviendra maintenant un
monsieur fuchs moi je ne suis pas fâché
venir sur le sol je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu' il y ait un
élargissement du g5 de la force
conjointe du g5 sahel dans le même
ensemble aux autres pays en particulier
aux pays du sud et des ronds peut
rentrer au pays du golfe qui peuvent
être victimes eux aussi de risques
terroristes dans le nord dans la
proximité de la frontière et dans le
nord de leur territoire par contre dans
au cours de la réunion qui s'est tenue à
djamena le président akuffo
président du ghana président la cedeao
en titre a proposé que les pays les plus
en sensibilité de risque de pénétration
des groupes terroristes dans le nord de
leur pays c'est à dire togo bénin ghana
côte d'ivoire entre autres
essentiellement cela s'organise entre
eux pour sécuriser collectivement leurs
propres frontières et avoir les moyens
de d'abord de dissuasion et de
coordination est aussi d'identification
des risques par un mécanisme un
dispositif de vigilance que l'union
européenne se prépare à financer qui
s'appelle le dispositif dit fade toute
autre hypothèse ne paraît pas pertinente
dans la mesure où par ailleurs l'esprit
la culture d'une défense commune d'une
solidarité de défense commune entre les
pays concernés est en train de monter en
puissance c'est un des effets de ce
sommet djamena et donc c'est tout à fait
opportun qu'on le maintienne
je vous avais parlé du moulin et parler
du mali mais se fixe sur le niger oui
saluons quand même monsieur fuchs le
fait que le président du niger et
renoncer et respecté complètement la
constitution ben moi je veux bien qu'on
critique les pays qui respectent pas
leur constitution mais quand les pays
respectent leur constitution ce qui est
le cas du niger parce que le président
issoufou a fait deux mandats et après il
dit je m'en vais et il ya un processus
électoral qui a été contrôlée et qui a
donné une victoire
oui monsieur bazoum de oui oui alors il
ya des gens qui contestent la victoire
d'accord il ya une commission électorale
haddock il ya des observateurs bon c'est
un processus compliqué mais moi je ne
vois pas pourquoi on ne dirait pas d'une
certaine manière bravo issoufou y en a
tant qui y compris y compris le tchad
dans dont vous parlez moi sur le tchad
je suis informé de
la sphère de monsieur il y aille a dit
löw
qui était sur le coup de deux mandats
d'arrêt antérieurement qui a posé de la
résistance des mandats judiciaire bon
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
aboutir à la perte de plusieurs vies
humaines et nous nous invitons
solennellement le tchad à conduire au
plus vite une enquête indépendante et
impartiale pour faire toute la lumière
sur cet événement tragique
je le dis publiquement et donc c'est
qu'il va y avoir des élections le 11
avril nous avons dit à de nombreuses
reprises aux autorités tchadiennes de
garantir la participation de
l'opposition ainsi que la liberté de
réunion et l'accès équilibrée aux médias
et c'est tout à fait essentiel pour la
stabilité du du tchad et nous avons fait
passer à plusieurs reprises au président
déby je suis allé moi-même porter ce
message directement à plusieurs reprises
ou produits auprès du président deby
donc je dis les choses très très
clairement nous regrettons ce qui s'est
passé et dès le décès de plusieurs
personnes dans l'entourage de monsieur
lié a di lo et je le dis publiquement ce
que je viens de dire voilà pour le tchad
et pour réponse à sueur pour revenir sur
monsieur fuchs faut quand même qu'on se
dise très clairement que les deux les
deux groupes
deux terroristes de gastes comme on dit
le mjs est arrivée m là y rattacher
directement des shs faut quand même
qu'on se le dise de temps en temps parce
que parfois on a tendance à l'oublier
on sait ce qu a fait des jo notre pays
ils sont rattachés directement à neige
c'est le cas de loïc ges et puis se
réveiller veine ils sont rattachés al
qaïda officiellement organiquement donc
ce n'est pas des choses anodines que
l'on donc l'on dit là et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle il ya des groupes
armés signataires et découvre armés
terroristes et que le combat mais et
terroristes y sont organisés et en lien
avec des organisations terroristes
internationales que nous combattons
partout il faut éviter que ce ce concert
pénètrent profondément en afrique et
c'est notre propre sécurité que nous
défendons aussi dans cette affaire alors
là je voudrais je reviens sur eux
le flanc suite j'en ai parlé sur la
turquie nous la question n'avait été
posée par le président effectivement je
n'avais pas répondu pour monsieur habib
nous nous constatons des évolutions
positives dans le discours il ya plus
d'insultés il y a
des discours rassurants il ya des gestes
verbaux attentionné y compris à notre
égard et puis il y à aussi dans les
faits deux éléments nouveaux il ya plus
de bateaux à ce stade dans les eaux
chypriotes et il y a par ailleurs une
volonté de re des discussions avec la
grèce voilà mais c'est très fragile
parce que la liste des désaccords est
très longue et dans le cadre du
président erdogan et le président en
vacances se sont entretenus vont
s'entretenir ce n'est pas arrivé depuis
longtemps et je vais moi même entretenir
à nouveau dans quelques temps avec mon
collègue là mais la liste des
contentieux est grande et j'ai toujours
dit que nous voulions nous avoir des
relations saines avec la turquie mais
qui ne cache pas les désaccords et qu'
on ne peut avoir des discussions de des
discussions de long terme avec ce pays
que si l'on peut avoir un dialogue que
si sa forme d' actes sont posés libye
l'irak
le haut karabagh en faire une liste très
longue queue qui aujourd'hui la grèce
j'en ai parlé et chypre tout cela
nécessite des actes on attend les ac
lors de l'union européenne à élaborer un
calendrier qui aboutira à une échéance
intermédiaire au mois de mars prochain
sur un rapport du haut commissaire
représentant monsieur borel et sur des
orientations qui sont prises au mois de
juin
donc voilà on dire plus moi j'ai
toujours dit que on ne pourrait se
positionner que lorsque des actes
seraient posés pour l'instant il n'ya de
poser surtout que des actes verbaux sur
l'iran je crois avoir dit les choses
il y avait un accord je sais que vous
contestez logique de cet accord l'accord
de vienne corps du cepeo à qui
permettait d'éviter que l'iran accède à
l'armé nucléaire
et je suis intimement convaincu que
c'est le processus de pression maximale
initiée par l'administration américaine
et le retrait des états unis de l'accord
de vienne qui aboutit de fait à ce que
l'iran est en situation relativement
rapidement d'accéder à l'art nucléaire
voilà et pas l inverse et c'est que vous
vous disiez je crois à mende les masques
vont tomber non c'est ça la réalité de
ce qui s'est passé depuis depuis 2000
non les masques pour l'instant on
m'aimait et donc nous nous souhaitons
vraiment que le processus de retour
progressif des états unis dans l'accord
et désir des iraniens sur leur
engagement
rompus de 2015 puisse se faire et qu'au
delà de cela on puisse aborder avec les
iraniens
la question des missiles la
prolifération missiles hier dans la zone
et la question de la stabilité régionale
en particulier dans le dans le golfe
mais il faut commencer par abou et le
bout on propose que ça vienne maintenant
leur problème de savoir qui commence et
kitty veut et que personne ne veulent se
faire piéger
mais la bonne la bonne démarche est
celle là donc le fait que les iraniens
et quitter renoncer au protocole
additionnel du traité de non
prolifération est une mauvaise nouvelle
dans tout cela
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur sur
ce coup sûr les observations de monsieur
alain david jeu quand j'avais déjà
beaucoup vous parlez de la birmanie
pendant mon propos de départ la
situation est très grave et les lisent
la l'initiative que vous proposez de gel
des sanctions
de gel des avoirs pardon c'est une
initiative que nous allons prendre au
niveau européen je crois je l'avais dit
que tout à l'heure
alors donc j'ai j'ai manqué j'aurais dû
le dire nous avons nous sommes engagés
sur alors je vais pas vous le décrire la
maintenant puisque nous sommes en séance
publique
mais nous allons prendre des initiatives
et ses terres il ya déjà des mesures
prises contre eux je crois c'est 14 18
militaires de haut rang d'avant en
raison de leur comportement par rapport
à la population réunie dia mais on va
renforcer cette réaction
et vous savez je n'ai pas dit c'est tout
à l'heure dans mon propos c'est c14
j'avais raison donc mais je tiens pas
une comptabilité de tous les sanctions
comme ça dans la tête mais du coup j'ai
oublié ce que j'allais dire non dans
lorsque nous prenons des sanctions nous
allons aux prises d'ailleurs à l'égard
de plusieurs pays on prend pas
uniquement des sanctions sur des
personnes auront aussi des sanctions sur
les entreprises
et quand je parle de gel des avoirs
s'est aussi déjà avoir d'entreprise
c'est pas le cas là en l'occurrence au
père m'a dit mais c'était le cas sur un
certain nombre d'entreprises dans
d'autres mesures de sanctions que nous
avons pris antérieurement et que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure
donc une très grande fermeté j'ai pas
fini
j'ai pas fini tout à fait j'ai reçu
monsieur lecoq qui monte en vous essayer
à chaque fois de mettre descoings sur le
coq
j'ai bien reçu le texte de
parlementaires français et allemands je
vais y répondre
je voudrais vous dire que la france
soutient la mobilisation de la
communauté internationale sur la
protection des civils dans les conflits
armés en zone habitée et nous défendons
l'application stricte du droit
international qui le protège nous
considérons ainsi que l'ami la mise en
oeuvre la promotion le partage des
pratiques les plus exigeantes
constituent des pistes d'actions utiles
au niveau international c'est dans cet
esprit de coopération que nous agissons
et nous soutenons la proposition
d'adopter une déclaration politique sur
ce sujet important et nous avons là
dessus
une position extrêmement ferme comme
vous pouvez vous en rendre compte mais
monsieur n'est pas de tête pas en ligne
en tout cas je le lui écrirai voilà si
j'étais au lit et je vous encore vous
merci je suis confronté à une situation
difficile
j'ai 19 ou 20 demandes de parole je
pense qu évidemment on ne peut pas faire
tout ça il nous reste une petite
demi-heure ce que je pense faire c'est
d'abord donné dans l'ordre n'ont pas à
un porte parole de 1,1 députés de chaque
groupe
et puis quand nous aurons fait cette
première c'est cette première chose on
passera un second député je voyage est
une très très forte représentation chez
14 14 demandes de paroles venant de la
reine et des demandes beaucoup plus
limité en nombre par deux hautes mais le
mini se propose de revenir la semaine
prochaine
enfin pour l'instant on va essayer de
faire ses premières questions donc
jean-françois me baï si vous voulez
commencer et ensuite on va tourner et on
verra si on peut aller un peu plus loin
mais j'arrête à j'arrête à 15,2 va dire
que le point le ministre et 15 minutes
pour vous répondre
allégis jean-françois oui merci monsieur
le président très rapidement de ceux de
ministre je voudrais d'avoir revenir sur
la situation en birmanie
alain david a évoqué cette question et
on voit que depuis ce week-end ailleurs
il y à une escalade de la violence dans
ce pays
nous avons tous entendu et partageant
les condamnations que vous formulez
vous-même et ministres du g7 ou encore
plus récemment l'union européenne
néanmoins nous aimerions en tout cas
j'aimerais savoir quelles sont les
actions entreprises par la france pour
permettre une désescalade rapide des
hostilités et pour amener à l'état pour
amener le retour à l'état de droit au
myanmar deuxième sujet que je voulais
aborder je ferai tout ça en une i30
monsieur le président c'est la situation
en haïti la situation en haïti avec là
aussi une légitimité du président
haïtien qui est contesté nous avons voté
il ya quelques heures un projet de loi
sur l'aide publique au développement
quelles sont les actions qui pourraient
permettre de résoudre cette crise en
tout cas de permettre à ce que haïti ne
soit plus dans cette crise que l'on que
l'on voit ce qui obère d'autant plus les
perspectives de développement d'haïti
troisième chose c'est une question que
je relaie de ma collègue ram laziali qui
voulait savoir quelle est telle qu'elle
était le premier bilan d'étape sur
l'accord-cadre france union des comores
et quel serait le nouveau calendrier
pour la tenue du second comité franco
comorien voilà j'ai tenu un nul 3-3 oui
merci vais chez le député mais celle en
cours
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
d'abord moi je veux partager la
satisfaction déjà formulées suite à la
large adoption du texte sur l'aide au
développement ce qui traduit
naturellement l'attachement de
beaucoup de nos collègues et
représentant pour cette politique est
inspiré par des valeurs en lien avec la
vocation historique de notre pays mais
ce qui traduit aussi à la fois l'esprit
et la méthode qui ont présidé à
l'élaboration et à l'examen de ce texte
est de ce point de vue je salue votre
implication personnelle en y associant
naturellement toutes celles et tous ceux
qui se sont eux aussi directement
impliqués élus et partenaires et de
conclure ainsi cette réussite collective
j'avais deux points le premier vous
l'avez abordé dans le cadre des
prolongements de la prise de fonction du
nouveau président des états unis
le premier point porté sur la situation
proche orient l'évolution du processus
de paix je veux parler plus précisément
de la question israélo-palestinienne
donc je voulais savoir si vous aviez les
éléments de connaissance et
d'appréciation sur ce que pourrait être
le positionnement de la nouvelle
administration américaine sur ses
relations avec les parties prenantes et
sa volonté ou non de favoriser la
relance d'un processus de paix sur des
bases respectueuse des résolutions des
nations-unies j'ai entendu tout à
l'heure vos déclarations qui marque
l'attachement des états unis à ces
résolutions sont apparaissent en tout
cas ce jour des perspectives
d'initiatives concrètes et l'autre fois
portée sur les prolongements du récent
sommet de n'djamena
je suis considéré comme un sommet à la
fois utile et nécessaire
je voulais
savoir parmi le réajustement où les
évolutions de l'action conduite au sahel
la volonté partagée de la montée en
puissance de l'union européenne étaient
fortement exprimés s'agissant notamment
de l'extension de son champ d'action de
la coordination du suivi politique avec
les autorités nationales et partenaires
associés comment cette articulation avec
l'engagement déterminant de la france
peut s'opérer
quel pays européens sont les plus
impliqués et qu'elle parte provisions
européen jean tél notamment sur le plan
du renforcement de sa contribution
financière
je vous remercie si vous pouviez être un
peu plus près avec madame politi merci
monsieur le président j'avais une
question qui est déjà été explicitée par
vous monsieur le ministre concernant la
birmanie et notamment sur si on peut
espérer une réponse ferme et unanime de
la part de l'union européenne sur ce
sujet là bon je pense que les
discussions sont en cours mais c'est
vraiment ce qu'il faut espérer
j'ai une deuxième question sur les
événements entre le haut karabakh et
l'arménie est-ce que vous pouvez nous
indiquer si le cessez le feu est bien
respectée si les craintes exprimées par
la population arménienne et notamment
pour leur sécurité aujourd'hui sont
fondées lorsque les forces armées
arméniennes dénonce la gouvernance
inefficace des autorités de tutelle a
qui font telle référence à la russie au
groupe de minsk
quel jour la cale rôle joue la france
désormais dans ce conflit et lors de son
audition en fin d'année dernière
l'ambassadeur azerbaïdjanais déclaré
avoir eu en sa possession les preuves
d'une intervention de mercenaires
français dans le conflit
est ce que le ministre des affaires
étrangères s'est entretenu avec
l'azerbaïdjan sur ce sujet merci je vous
remercie madame du monde
bérengère voilà je voulais évoquer la
dégradation continue et préoccupant des
conditions d'exercice des droits de
l'homme en guinée 27 janvier vous avez
fait part de votre décision d'accorder
la protection politique à monsieur
diallo opposants politiques du président
alpha condé décision que je salue
cependant plus de 400 opposants sont
toujours incarcérés dans des conditions
déplorables ayant conduit à la mort de
plusieurs des plus quand d'autres font
état de maladie sans que leurs
conditions ne soient aménagés ces
personnes détenues sont également coupés
de tout contact avec le monde extérieur
que ce soit leurs familles mais
également leurs avocats cela me laisse
la voie et les efforts de la france sont
très attendus vous le savez dès lors
quelles actions le ministère at il prévu
d'entreprendre pour intercéder en faveur
de la libération de ces détenus
politiques dont le régime guinéen ni
jusqu'à l'existence
d'autre part un rapport d'amnesty
international fait état d'un programme
financé par l'union européenne visant à
développer les services de sécurité
guinéen jusqu'en 2022 le parce le
programme d'appui à la réforme du
secteur de sécurité qui accompagnent qui
forme et qui équipe les services de
sécurité guinéens dans le but de lutter
contre le terrorisme ou le trafic de
drogue
il serait sans doute nécessaire que la
france s'assure auprès de l'union
européenne que cet appui soit
exclusivement utilisé à ces fins et non
des tournées vers la répression des
populations
par ailleurs les événements récents
impose de faire l'inventaire des
programmes d aide et de financement que
la france elle même dédié à la guinée à
des fins de sécurité afin d'éviter que
ces derniers ne soient dévoyées de leur
objectif premier
donc merci de m'indiquer si les actions
ont été entreprises en ce sens et
lesquelles merci beaucoup madame la
députée madame roche
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
ministre je voulais vous interroger sur
les vaccins en effet dans cette pandémie
qui nous touche tous
un des axes de sortie et la vaccination
et nous vaincrons ce virus que si nous
parvenons à développer une vaccination
partout dans le monde et en particulier
en afrique
l'idée que la france a porté en g7 fin
février personne ne sera en sécurité
tant que le monde entier ne sera pas
c'est la raison d'être du mécanisme
kovacs mise en place par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et dont l'objectif
est d'accélérer la mise au point et la
fabrication de vaccins contre la copie
de 19 et d'en assurer un accès juste et
équitable à l'échelle mondiale il s'agit
d'ailleurs du plus grand déploiement de
vaccins de l'histoire et l'équipe europe
en est le premier contributeur
c'est aussi le fondement de l'approché
européenne ou des efforts de
coordination engagé depuis le début de
la pandémie montre de plus en plus sans
nécessité leur efficacité
aussi monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous préciser quelle est la stratégie de
la france dans cette géopolitique du
vaccin et de la vaccination et j'avais
une deuxième question puisque je me fais
le porte voix de mon collègue lenec adam
qui est empêchée et qui le qui
souhaitait vous interroger sur la mise
en place de dispositifs visant à
faciliter d'entrées légales des
ressortissants suriname et en guyane
particulièrement les commerçants et si
chacun bien compris et intégré la
nécessité de fermeture des frontières
il souhaite à nouveau vous sensibiliser
sur ce point avec par exemple la mise en
place d'une carte de frontaliers au même
titre qu'à la frontière brésilienne ou
encore un visa à prix réduit ou gratuits
pour les suriname et souhaitant se
rendre en guyane en guyane pardon pour
moins de 24 heures je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
merci merci madame la députée je vais
donner la parole à monsieur deflesselles
j'essaie de tourner merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre juste un
mot sur un sujet que vous avez effleuré
mais qui est très important c'est le
retour bien sûr des états unis dans
l'accord de paris vous avez parlé de la
coke 26 quai la coop de glasgow elle va
être fondamentale elle va être
fondamentale pourquoi parce qu'on va
revisiter en langage onusien lysienne
décès c'est à dire en fait les
contributions des 180 pays qui étaient
dans la cour de paris
le retour de
dub hayden est donc là je dirais le
retour des etats-unis dans l'accord de
paris c'est une bonne chose kerry c'est
une bonne chose également parce qu'il
est très sensible à ces questions là
l'autre bonne chose c'est le 22 avril ce
sommet que veulent le organisé les états
unis par contre il ya des facettes un
peu moins favorable pour rappeler
simplement que chaque américain par
capita ses 16 tonnes d'émissions de co2
pour mémoire la france et cape town et
demi pour mémoire la chine ces sept
tonnes
8 donc la négociation va être
terriblement difficile monsieur le
ministre
et vous le savez à glasgow ça sera au
ministre des affaires étrangères au
ministère de l'environnement qui sera au
siège vous rappelez de l'accord de paris
vous rappelez dans 2015 la bataille qui
a vu entre laurent fabius et ségolène
royal s'étaient fa bus en tant que
ministre des affaires étrangères qui
avait présidé la coupe de paris donc il
va falloir tous les deux et vous ne
serez pas trop négociés et re négocier
je dirais la l'accord de paris en tout
cas sa déclinaison parce que c'est vital
3° et demi aujourd'hui l'augmentation
prévue par le giec
on est très très loin des 1 degré et
demi au des deux degrés de l'accord de
paris si monsieur le député dernier ne
donne pas le dernier orateur aura triché
inscrits mais le dernier à qui on peut
donner la parole ce sera madame marion
l'aide qui est en vision et ensuite le
ministre répondra on sera tous merci
monsieur le président le ministre fera
venir sur la deuxième assemblée générale
de l'alliance elle du 15 février dernier
à djamena vous y avez rappelé la volonté
de la france de relancer le projet de la
grande muraille verte destinée à lutter
contre la désertification et les effets
du changement climatique dans la bande
sahélo saharienne
pourtant le rideau de verdure de plus de
8000 kilomètres du sénégal à djibouti
dessine une ligne discontinue seulement
4 millions d'hectares ont été aménagés
sur les 100 millions prévu
officiellement depuis près de quinze ans
déjà et soit 4% de ce programme de
restauration écologique au service de la
lutte contre la pauvreté je me souviens
même pas quand j'habite
et en ethiopie en 97 on en parlait déjà
c'est quand même un projet et qui
finalement a plus de 25 ans alors selon
l'agencé panafricaine de la grande
muraille verte 200 millions de dollars
ont été mobilisés dont 150 millions
proviennent de financement étranger le
reste étant pris en charge par les états
eux mêmes selon les donateurs il
s'agirait de 870 millions de dollars
avec marc ferret d'une tête nous nous
sommes orateurs des opérations pardon
seraient menées en dehors du tracé
initialement prévue par les pays
africains dans les temps qu'auparavant
le mien five est alors par ailleurs il
semblerait que les gouvernements à
l'exception du sénégal et de l'éthiopie
n'ont pas placé cette priorité en tête
de leur feuille de route
on peut se demander pourquoi se glisse
aussi lors du sommet one planet ce mythe
de janvier 14 3 milliards de dollars ont
été collectés pour ce projet pouvez vous
nous dire quel sera à l'agenda de la
france pour le portage de la sécurité
alimentaire de la souveraineté
alimentaire de la bande
sahélo-saharienne jour merci merci merci
madame la députée monsieur le ministre
bouquet de questions auxquelles vous
avez peu de temps pour répondre et le
parquet est à vous comme on dit en
anglais
excusez moi peut-être pas dans l'ordre
mais personne je pense
je devrais le retour était le préalable
en sachant que les états unis sont le
premier émetteur et en sachant qu'il y à
cet horizon de glasgow qui à l'événement
du 22 avril c'est là qu'on va juger ou
le curseur va va se mettre déjà parlé
avec kerry qui tout à fait à l'anc et
l'expérience du de l'ancien des accords
de paris
il faut évidemment que les mises
affaires étrangères s'en occupe
mon interlocuteur chinois s'est mise
affaires étrangères et je parle avec
monsieur wang li sur ces questions il
faut que j'avais il faut qu'on avance
aussi avec eux parce que c'est vrai que
c'est laid end et les jours d'ici du
cndc vont être décidées à ce moment là
et que c'est tout à fait essentiel
d'autant plus qu' il y aura par ailleurs
trois 3 autres
enfin deux autres conventions parce
qu'il ya la convention de la
biodiversité et la convention sur la
désertification qu'on va essayer de
réunir ensemble au moment de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies avant glasgow
puisque pour essayer de créer une
dynamique collective
si d'aventuré on peut le faire au niveau
sanitaire en septembre prochain
oui mais le mon ministère est totalement
partie prenante de cette discussion sur
sur la birmanie plusieurs d'entre vous
m'ont interrogé mais j'ai pas beaucoup
d'autres choses à dire que ce que j'ai
déjà dit à deux ou trois reprises dans
mon propos initial et en répondant au
porte parole des groupes
simplement que nous allons renforcer les
nouvelles mesures restrictives
individuel à l'égard des représentants
ou des hauts représentants de la junte
militaire avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
fermeté donc tout cela est en cours avec
aussi une pression internationale que
nous ne manquons pas de poursuivre dans
les semaines qui viennent
en portant plus le dossier au niveau de
l'asian même si pour l'instant la sienne
n'a pas été extrêmement offensive sur le
sujet parce que disons les choses très
clairement il ya aussi la question
chinoise
quand on parle de ces régions il faut
toujours penser que la chine est proche
et alors sur la situation en haïti comme
ça je fais de réponse monsieur bail et
madame ali voilà parce que monsieur by
ap le porte-parole de madame avis ce
sont des rues zone et sur le plan sur la
situation en haïti que vous évoquez
c'est vrai que la situation est
extrêmement préoccupante et ne cesse de
se dégrader depuis maintenant deux ans
le parlement ayant cessé de siéger
depuis février 2000 2020 nous nations
unies nous nous poursuivons une
expression du conseil de sécurité qui
doit permettre d' exprimer très
clairement les attentes du conseil de
sécurité vis-à-vis du gouvernement moïse
mais aussi de son opposition pour
rétablir les conditions minimales
d'exercice d'une vie démocratique et
sécuritaire acceptable cela suppose que
le rétablissement des institutions se
met en place et cela suppose la tenue
d'élections législatives et
présidentielle crédible en 2021 avec une
observer une observation internationale
c'est ce que nous allons essayer de
faire en tout cas il n'appartient pas à
la france de dicter son choix aux
haïtiens mais nous sommes liés à ce pays
par l'histoire par la langue et nous
avons des efforts importants dans le
plan humanitaire donc nous ne pourrons
pas nous désintéresser du processus
politique que nous essayons de mettre en
oeuvre par le biais des nations unies et
pour la question des comores pour madame
ali je sais qu'ils s'intéressent
beaucoup à ce sujet nous avons passé moi
j'ai signé un accord en 2010 9 un
document cadre de partenariat avec les
autorités comoriennes
il comporte des engagements réciproques
qui se comporte un plan de développement
de 150 millions d'euros donc nous avons
considérablement augmenter notre aide
aux comores et l'application continue à
se mettre en oeuvre même si
il ya encore des points qui nécessitent
une des ajustements je m'en suis
entretenu ce mois ci pendant le mois
dernier avec mon collègue de cloud 12
kamal pardon j'ai du mal à prononcer et
nous allons tenir la seconde réunion du
comité franco comorien des au niveau
d'aix de la situation sanitaire nous
permettra de le faire et sa victoire
nous avons mis un dispositif qui fait en
sorte que les élus de mayotte puis sept
partenaires partie de ce dispositif est
donc j'espère qu'ils seront à ce rendez
vous malgré les les difficultés
sanitaire mais parce que nous avons mis
un protocole sanitaire robuste entre la
france et les comores les opérations de
reconduite des flux d'immigration
clandestine se poursuivent normalement
même si de temps en temps nous rappelons
les autorités comoriennes à leurs
engagements sur ce sujet alors autrement
sur sur le haut
madame politi sur le haut-karabagh sur
l'arménie les layènes crise interne
vous connaissez non ça sonne chez madame
l'aisne
elle nie l élevage au règlement c'est
pas moi qui va dire entrer elle nie
catégoriquement
nous la croyons sur parole bonetti à la
question que vous me posiez sur les les
relations avec la force armée
moi ce que j'ai vu c'est des deux
mouvements de l'autorité militaire
contre le premier ministre à chignon et
que ça c'est un premier élément est que
par ailleurs le chef de l'état
sarkissian aujourd'hui a refusé de
signer la décision de monsieur pashinian
de limoger le chef d'état major
donc ça devient un peu compliqué moi
j'aime pas me mêler de cela nous n'avons
pas nous et de sa célèbre des problèmes
internes à l'arménie mais sur le
haut-karabagh nous veillons à ce que
donc ça que ça concernait comme votre
interrogation audi est ce qui s qui
était visé c'était un problème interne à
l'arménie qui est en crise
aujourd'hui alors au dos au niveau du
fonctionnement interne de la démocratie
arménienne j'ai pas de jugement à porter
en souhaitant simplement que ça se passe
dans la sérénité dans le calme et dans
le respect des institutions
sur le reste nous sommes toujours une
relation avec l'art minimes j'ai vu mon
collègue je me reçu mon collègue
arménien il ya peu de jours pour
envisager avez vu comment on peut
soutenir jean baptiste lemoyne s'est
rendu en arménie
il s'est aussi rendu en azerbaïdjan nous
avons conforté un prêt de politique
publique avec l'arménie pour lui
permettre de sortir des difficultés
financières nous en avons fait part de
notre disponibilité pour les efforts
d'investissement et de développement
économiques qui
propose dans le cadre de l'application
des accords qui ont été passés lors de
la fin de l'ère de la crise sous réserve
que nous intérêts soit tout à fait
respecté moi je ne suis pas au courant
de ce type d'activité des mercenaires
français qui je n'ai pas de deux poids
particulier sur la formation
particulière sur ce point
donc si j'avais des informations je vous
en ferai pas mais je n'en ai pas tout
n'est pas réglé dans l'application du
cessez-le-feu et encore des enjeux de
prisonniers qui ne sont pas réglés nous
poussons des deux côtés pour que ça
puisse aboutir
mais par ailleurs le groupe de minsk
continue à fonctionner avec un
représentant usées représentants
américains et représentant français il
ya un ambassadeur qui cela sur visconti
et qui je rencontre me rencontrent
régulièrement de tout cela nous sommes
rassurés
pourquoi non c'est non mais c'est une
question de tout vous faut garder bien
sûr quand même assez horrifiée par qui
chez lui c'est sûr il me reste la
question ça j'ai fini sur la question
posée par monsieur joncour voix sur
israël palestine je crois que j'ai
répondu pour l'instant
il ya des choses qui ont qui ont bougé
j'en ai fait état tout à l'heure dans
mon propos initial sur le
multilatéralisme sur le cadre
international sur la deux états sur
l'opposition exact multilatéraux il ya
des choses qui ne bouge pas et qui ne
changeront pas l'ambassade à jérusalem
jérusalem capitale d'israël et d'autres
qui restent plus lointaines en
perspective comme le la réouverture de
bureaux de l'ol paie à washington mais
indépendamment du niveau de priorité qui
sera accordée par les états unis
car les priorités régionales sont très
nombreuses pour aujourd'hui pour la
diplomatie américaine
nous nous allons continuer le travail
que nous avions engagés nous allons
faire aussi envoûtante en essayant de
mettre dans le coup les les états unis
et nous en avons exprimé le souhait lors
de notre réunion à 4 que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure nous sommes vus au caire au
mois de janvier au moment de falla il ya
peu il ya peu de temps pour lancer cette
politique de nouvelles initiatives sur
le proche orient sur relay le sahel ce
qui ce qui est frappant c'est que ça
devient vraiment monsieur jean cours une
affaire européenne le haut niveau
militaire la force takouba qui
va agir de contre le terrorisme en
accompagnement de barkan et de la force
conjointe regroupe maintenant au jeudi
de mémoire mais mes collaborateurs 19,9
pays qui s'il veut aussi associer
certains sont déjà présents l'estonie me
république tchèque portugal l'italie ce
mouvement là existent la réunion de la
coalition pour le sahel donc des 45 pays
qui sont dispensés acteurs qui sont dans
vigilance en intention soutien à ce que
l'on fait au sahel les uns et les autres
pas se tenir à berlin ce qui montre que
l'engagement européen se fait y compris
financièrement je peux pas vous donner
les chiffres d'engagements financiers
répartis au sein de l'alliance à elle
mais est politiquement et financièrement
et militairement
l'enjeu sahélien devient progressivement
européen ça n'a rien à voir avec ce que
j'avais connu au départ pour le surinam
je sais plus qui me poser la question
sur le surinam
mais à d'accord sur le ciri nam je vais
traiter ou est-ce que les nombreux jeux
vais je vous dirai à votre collègue que
normalement je vais signer
peut-être même lac dès la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
avec les autorités de surinam un traité
de délimitation de la frontière à
l'occasion de déplacements à paris de
mon collègue me lisent affaires
étrangères de surinam sur délimitation
de la frontière qui est une avancée
considérable puisqu'il fallait que ce
soit clarifié que ça c'était la
condition pour que il y a une vraie
coopération
ce 9 frontière commune même si on sait
on le sait très bien les il ya des
incidents toujours sur le fleuve maroni
c'est toujours un peu compliqué de
lutter contre l'orpaillage illégal
ça nécessite une vraie clarification sur
la frontière
et enfin nous sommes parvenus à ce
résultat est donc cette signature va
avoir lieu dans quelques jours les élus
ont été informés tout ça mais c'est une
bonne avancée sur sur la muraille verte
je crois que vous avez marion laine a
tout dit entre ce que j'ai dit moi au
début est ce que vous avez dit vous
madame députés il ya un instant vous
avez dit l'essentiel et saas est
l'initiative de la grande muraille verte
regroupe onze états
du sénégal à djibouti et elle est gérée
par une fille tuée en
mauritanie madame du monde interrogé
aussi sur position non seulement ça
marche oui ça marche bien et donc c'est
bien
on est dans l'accélération de la grande
muraille verte puisque ça a été pendant
très longtemps un sujet symbolique et
non pas un sujet d'efficacité et la
france est pleinement mobilisé déjà pour
concrétiser sur le terrain
les objectifs fixés par cette initiative
et nous avons engagé en particulier au
tchad puisqu'on en parle n beau
plusieurs projets dans le domaine
agricole en particulier dans le
maraîchage dans les oléagineux et nous
avons développé une assistance technique
pour faire en sorte qu'en tirent le
meilleur profit des eaux de pluie et
nous aurons aussi un projet d'appui 250
millions d'euros dans le tibesti qui
contribueront à la mise en oeuvre de
cette grande muraille verte ces sept
mille huit cents kilomètres entre
djibouti et le sénégal essais en quinze
kilomètres de largeur c'est un projet
gigantesque mais considérables pour
lutter contre la désertification pour
réinstaller les acteurs agricoles dans
l'agro pastoralisme
c'est vraiment un projet le chien qui a
été pendant longtemps sous-estimée et
que nous voulons vraiment remettre au
meilleur niveau
voilà madame
du monde sur la situation en guinée moi
je me suis exprimé publiquement de déjà
à plusieurs reprises sur le sujet la
cour constitutionnelle guinéenne a
confirmé la victoire de monsieur alpha
condé nous avons pris note mais nous
avons exprimé de nos interrogations sur
le processus électoral on a condamné les
violences
voilà mes 30 ans j'ai envie de dire et
alors qu'est ce qu'il faut vous voulez
qu'on fasse en plus qu'on rentre nos
relations diplomatiques avec la guinée
quand on supprime toute aide à la guinée
c'est à dire aux populations
c'est donc la voie quand on est sur le
site les situations là qui est qu'il est
juste de dénoncer ensuite quand on passe
ça comment est ce qu'on peut faire mieux
c'est jamais simple et je peux vous dire
que j'ai moi même exprimé dans tête à
tête mais opposition au président alpha
condé le lui dit qu'on ne partage pas
cette cette manière de faire de là il y
à la vie des guinéens qui aujourd'hui
est encore touché par par les mollahs
mais donc bas pour lutter contre les
mollahs bon travail avec le président
condé
que voulez-vous que je vous dise c'est
ça la réalité et on a raison que me
semble-t-il sur les vaccins c'était nous
avions joué cdma la roja à titre pour
votre propre compte
donc nous sur le fond c'est bien évident
que il n'y aura de réponse à la pandémie
que de réponse globale et donc à les
aider les pays 92 pays qui font partie
de l'ensemble des bénéficiaires de
l'opération kovacs c'est à la fois
devoir de solidarité mais aussi à devoir
d'efficacité et donc ce le mouvement a
commencé puisque l'opération kovacs a
permis de mobiliser plus de 2 milliards
je crois que 2 milliards 300 millions
qui ont commencé à être acheminée au
ghana en côte d'ivoire au bénin qui
devrait permettre ensuite un
élargissement mais il faut être sûr
qu'elles soient non seulement à cheminer
qu'est ce que les deux soient bien
conservés dont il ya que quelques
systèmes qui peuvent le système faiza ne
marche pas par exemple dans dans ce
genre de situation mais avec l'arrivée
de astrazeneca et peut-être bientôt de
johnson johnson ne devrait pouvoir
répondre à ces demandes c'est essentiel
c'est il en va de notre solidarité
initiative que nous avions prise sur
l'impulsion du président de la
république était je crois
l'initiative indispensable je crois que
j'ai fini d'écouter chevaux je vous
remercie vous avez dépassé de quelques
minutes le temps que vous vous étiez
donner ce dont je vous suis très
reconnaissant
ce que je voudrais je vais pas tirer
conclusion sinon pour dire un mot le mot
c'est que nous avons en vous écoutant
nous avons vu constater ce que nous
pensions c'est que l'amérique était de
retour
nous avons vu les initiatives que vous
preniez ce que nous attendons ce que
nous attendons c'est que l'europe soit
de retour nous ne voulons pas simplement
assister au retour de l'amérique et nous
comptons sur la france pour le faire
alors nous vous n'avez pas répondu à
toutes les questions parce qu'elle ne
vous ont pas été toutes posées on verra
si on peut coincer dans votre emploi du
temps et dans l'autre une réunion la
semaine prochaine pour prolonger cette
discussion ce devrait être si c'était
possible je crois que le seul vraiment
qu'ils seraient
possible serait mercredi après midi on
verra je ne peux pas promettre à la
commission quoi que ce soit à ce sujet
si l'on regarde jalons nous allons
étudier tout cela et demain mes chers
donc merci monsieur le ministre ce tour
d'horizon extrêmement large
j'avais essayé de canaliser mais sans
aucun succès vous avez vous avez répondu
vous avez tu avais j'avais été votre
interlocuteur votre interprète pour
essayer de museler mais mes collègues ça
n'a pas du tout marché
vous avez vous fait briser mes efforts
en répondant avec oleg c'est très bien
demain mes chers collègues nous nous
retrouvons à 9h30
ici autour de pascal lamy en présentiel
et en vision je vous remercie